do we have enough left for tomorrow we
don't have tomorrow good Ben Shapiro we
are live the people have spoken well
thank you for having me thanks for being
here man I became a fan of yours when I
watched you with what the [ __ ] is his
name the CNN Piers Morgan oh that was
glorious when you went after him dissent
with the Sandy Hook thing like right
away immediately like it was just
glorious and you could tell that he
didn't know what to do with it and he
literally said how dare you which is
what I say with to people all the time
when I'm joking yes thank you was
clutching his pearls he he was really
pissed he was it was a two segment
interview and during the break I said to
him thanks so much for having me on it
kind of growled at me he was not a happy
camper yeah well you crushed him and the
other one of my other favorite ones was
Chelsea Handler crushing him or she was
literally talking like you don't even
talk to me in the brake and the brake
you're checking your phone and checking
Twitter and you could tell he was like
oh no he just you know he came from that
weird British tabloid environment and
you found out that the company that he
worked for did really creepy [ __ ] like
check people's voicemails they hacked
into people's people who are dead and
they gave the family false hope because
they had checked the voicemail and they
found out that someone checked in they
thought oh maybe she's still alive and
then we made him a host unlike the
x-factor and brought him on Sienna is
awesome I just decision all around why
CNN thought that we have this
fascination with British people yes if
you have a British accent we
automatically had 20 points to IQ yeah
they're great for like selling mops late
night and nonstick cookware and I
enjoyed John Oliver I think John Oliver
is great apparently he has you know a
lot of people think of all British
accents as being the same but he has
like blue collar British accent but I
don't I can't tell the difference too
much except when I'm watching my fair
lady or something well I could tell
people from like Manchester and stuff
like that because they you know they
they have like this sort of like way of
talking so fast that all the words kind
of pile into each other but uh yeah
Oliver's his his recent one any Bravo
got really matter
the recent one about Alex Jones is
[ __ ] hilarious
well you see it's almost impossible to
make something not funny about Alex
Jones yeah you gotta meet Alex have you
met him
I don't know that given how much I've
made fun of him strip off his shirt and
start he might calm down you're a good
guy we're basically on the same team
come around if you remember the Piers
Morgan thing happened two nights after
Alex was on Piers Morgan so element so
appears was like flying high because he
had that whole debate with Alex and Alex
did his schtick and it was really over
the top and he thought I was gonna be
like Alex Jones par tunas gonna be peers
you know succeeds again and Alex and I
could not be more different than richest
no you're very rational and very
reasonable and you know we've been
talking about some of your debates
there's not a lot of guys like you out
there which is really interesting it's
like you're a fast thinking fast talking
very smart young guy who's also a
conservative like there's not a lot of
those out there and this is one of the
things that we're encountering today is
they're especially on college campuses
there's this very strange separation
between the left and the right to the
point where the right is like almost
non-existent or at least doesn't have
any representation and they're actively
shunning that representation like
they're pushing people out I know what's
going on with you and Berkeley has been
resolved yeah I think that so Berkeley
after the publicity they said they're
gonna explain to people if they don't
know the whole story yes so UC Berkeley
if you recall last year I actually spoke
there before any of this happened I
spoke at UC Berkeley in like April 2016
and then Milo was supposed to speak
there and he actually went there and
there was a riot where an Tifa
infiltrated the the student community
and there are all these pictures of them
bombing things and you know blowing up
cars and under setting them to fire at
least and throwing things at windows and
so Berkeley shut down that event for
safety reasons then Ann Coulter wanted
to speak there and they basically used
what they call time place and manner
restrictions to stop her they kept
saying we have safety problems we can't
figure out how to do the events and in
the end they just canceled that because
they didn't have security and then young
America's Foundation which sponsors me
to go to a lot of these campuses they
said we want Shapiro to come and again I
spoke there like a year and a half ago
and they give them two and a half months
advance and Berkeley said well we have
no venues available and so
this seemed to be another cover for
we're not going to allow a conservative
on campus because there are security
problems so we made that public and then
Berkeley said no no well we'll make
we'll make sure that you get in they
give us an alternative venue and so they
even said they'd cover the security they
didn't like the bad publicity oh well
that's nice yes that should be good well
you know what happened with Jordan
Peterson yesterday yes
yeah just yesterday Jordan Peterson was
banned from YouTube and YouTube has a
new policy that uh it's very it's very
weirdly worded but apparently they're
allowed to block and restrict any kind
of videos that are about religion or
that could be deemed offensive which is
almost everything yeah that's right
anything that's remotely if I mean
anything that's interesting is going to
be offensive to somebody so it won't be
monetized
it also won't be in the emoto's of
interest or I know they did this to
Prager University as well they blocked
like ten of their videos a couple of
months ago so it's it's yeah I mean this
is nasty stuff and listen YouTube's a
private company they have the right to
do what they want but don't proclaim
that you're a free speech promoting
institution if you're gonna block people
like Jordan Peterson for God's sake well
the problem is they're not blocking
things that are offensive to other
people they're not blocking certain
things that are representing Islam in a
positive light that's right there's
there's a lot of weirdness with this
left-wing choice of what to censor and
what not to censor and it's it's not
just dangerous it's also bad for the
whole idea of being a progressive or
being a liberal because it makes you
look it makes them look really petty and
really weird and really resistant and
hesitant to actually have real debate
yeah for sure I mean this is one of the
reasons why I'm very meticulous in my
terminology about people who are on the
other side of the aisle actually
separate people who are liberal from
people who are leftist so when they're
people who try to ban speech I call them
leftist and if they are not interested
in banning speech then their liberal
meaning they they want bigger government
they disagree with me on politics but
they're still willing to have a
conversation they want an open forum
people who are on the hard left think
that it's actually an insult to their
identity to disagree with them and this
is what I experience sometimes on
campuses you know at Cal State LA where
there's a near riot when I speak or
University of Wisconsin where people
storm the stage and stand in front of it
and won't leave Penn State
we have again another near violence
incident over at Penn State or DePaul
where they actually banned me outright
so sometimes you get this routine from
people who think that they conflate
their viewpoint with their identity and
then if you have a different viewpoint
you're denying them their humanity and
it's like no I'm not denying you I just
think what you're saying is dumb like
that's a very good point that's a very
good point is that they have their
identity completely connected with their
ideology and when you oppose these
people when you have these debates of
these people what's really fascinating
is the level of a stereo that gets
reached while you're staying calm yeah
that's what I've noticed is is that
there's a ton of you know I tend to keep
relatively calm just as a human being
and very often when I'm debating someone
you see them getting more and more and
more emotional and people on the right
love this because of course it's the
triggering of the snowflakes but the
easiest thing in the world to do is
trigger some idiot college kid who
doesn't know his ass from a hole in the
ground and what's what's hard to do is
actually discuss issues with somebody
who's intelligent enough to make the to
make the point but it's it that the
level of hysteria on the campuses has
really increased I mean I don't have to
travel with two members of security to
every campus just because you don't know
which campus is gonna go off I never had
to travel a security before it's the
weirdest thing in the world how long did
this start happening
well February of 2016 is when I started
traveling with security so I spoke at
University of Missouri they remember
they had a big blowup at University of
Missouri with black lives matter taking
over campus offices and suggesting
there's some sort of big racism problem
at Mizzou which is just ridiculous and
so they flew me and I did a speech there
and then the next time I spoke was Cal
State LA and they brought in a couple of
security guys and I was like what do I
need security for man I'm just speaking
on a campus who cares we get to the
campus and they had already tried to
cancel my speech because of security and
I said I'm coming anyway so tough I had
to be escorted in by 20 armed police
officers I had to be escorted off campus
by motorcycle cops flashing their lights
there were 300 students who had blocked
all of the entrances were physically
assaulting people trying to get into the
theater the police had to sneak the
students in two-by-two into the theater
they told them that until I left the
campus they couldn't actually let the
kids out of the theater because they
were afraid that if they let the kids
out of the theater they'd be attacked as
they got as they were released it was
that one was pretty wild so after that
it was like okay well I guess the
security is necessary what is shifting
like what what is what is ramping
I think the identity politics is ramping
things up so I think there's a new
mentality out there it's the this
intersectionality politics on the left
that says that they're a bunch of victim
groups basically are their blacks and
Hispanics and gays and Jews and Asians
they're all victim groups and we get
those all those people together to
attack the system because the system is
keeping them down and if you and there's
a hierarchy among these victim groups
and if you are a straight white male
you're at the very very bottom of the
hierarchy in terms of viewpoints that
should be acknowledged because you're
the creators of this vast white
supremacist system that keeps down
everybody else if you're a black woman
you're near the top right if you're LGBT
you're at the top if you're a white guy
and you challenge the viewpoint of a
black woman your viewpoint is an attack
on her identity and therefore she has
the right to shut you down and so the
idea is that your words are violence to
her identity and therefore she has the
right to react this is the term you hear
on campus a lot is microaggressions this
idea that my opinion micro aggresses you
now even that terminology I think is
really stupid because normally in
regular life we would say that's
insulting and you said something I don't
like the terminology microaggressions
suggests aggression like I'm actually
doing something aggressive to you and
the rational response to someone
aggressing you is to use physical force
in response and so you saw you start to
see a more violent response I think
that's it's been growing in our politics
I think there's a reactionary side on
the right that's that's growing and if
there's an identity politics on the left
that says no black eyed any politics gay
identity politics female identity
politics I think you're starting to see
in some areas of white identity politics
that's almost formed in response like
okay well if everybody else gets to have
their identity politics why can't we
defend ourselves on those same grounds I
hate that [ __ ] I hate that [ __ ] too and
I would like to find the person who
invented the term microaggression that
[ __ ] whoever it was they they created
quite a mess now I'm sure you saw what
happened in Evergreen with Brett
Weinstein where literally the left is
eating itself and that's where it gets
crazy is like you're not progressive
enough unless you're literally
submitting to leaving your class because
you're white like you can't be there
because you're white they want a day of
absence
meaning the professor's the white people
and then when you don't do it you're
somehow another racist and a Nazi I mean
the whole thing is the
whole thing was very bizarre to watch
but but not sure not surprising because
you see it so much so often all over the
country right now and it's almost like
some new flower of ridiculous thinking
and behavior yet has blossomed and it's
in bloom everywhere and when people
could point to it existing in other
places like in Missouri with that woman
that was your name Crick was that woman
who click yeah yeah whatever her name
was yeah but when you see it in video
when you see her on video saying can we
get some muscle over here exactly like
this is [ __ ] insane like you're
telling a photographer and by the way a
minority an asian asian man taking
photos of a public place that you've
created some safe space but it's it's
it's this weird thing where it's half of
it as identity politics but it's also
wrapped up in this need to control
people and control people's behavior
control their vernacular control the way
they communicate and how you know how
much you give in to groupthink it's it's
weird it's it's scary and a Jonathan
Hyde is a social psychologist over done
why you hit a really good piece for the
Atlantic in 2015 about this phenomenon
this kind of safe space trigger warning
phenomena on this idea that you must
never be forced into a position where
someone has an idea that opposes yours
and what he said is it basically makes
people crazy you know it actually makes
you crazy that the idea in psychology is
that if you have a chain of thoughts
leading to a bad outcome if you're
depressed or if you're depressive then
you have a chain of thoughts leading to
a bad outcome the way that psychologists
deal with that is with cognitive
behavioral therapy they say ok we're in
this chain of thoughts are you going
wrong are you attributing to somebody a
motive they don't have right is your
wife really being nasty or is it you
just attributing nasty to her and that's
why you're getting depressed you're
spinning off right try to control your
own train of thoughts what the
microaggression trigger warning culture
does is it actually grants lay out the
more you are offended the more value you
are granted and therefore you have
actually an interest in being offended
we give you awards if you're offended
right you're you're treasured if you're
offended because it demonstrates that
you're woke right you're well the more
you are offended the more we can show
that you are woke and because you are
woke therefore you're granted this
virtue you get to lord it over everyone
else I mean I say in my speeches if we
could somehow identify like the LGBTQ
half black half Hispanic 1/4 Native
American little person you know then we
would finally have the the person who we
could go to to answer all of our
questions because their identity would
be unquestionable biota right if we
could find Yoda we could just get rid of
democracy in discussion all together
he just rule from on high he she I don't
want to put a gender on Yoda right I
don't think yo does Genoa gotta be a guy
deep voice maybe we're being rude but
inside no but yeah you're absolutely
right is no one is uh no one's left
enough yeah it's it's I don't know where
the limit is and it's they're so far
left that they've actually made come and
cross with the people they hate right so
then they talk about safe spaces and say
it yet Missouri yet all these black
students protesting and they actually
said we don't want white people who
think like us and who want to help us in
our safe spaces we feel insulted by that
I just thought to myself oh the KKK
agrees like if you want to do safe
spaces for separate races I can find
some Jim Crow racists are totally up for
that from like 1962 well there's the the
really bizarre statement that I've heard
over and over again that black people
cannot be racist against white people
because they don't have any power over
white people yes Wow which is just it's
inane I mean it's in the naiton
statement this idea that you have to you
have to have power in the superstructure
in order for you to even to be erased I
can understand the argument if they said
look you being racist is not connected
to racist action if you don't have the
capacity for action that affects people
then your personal racism is not as
important as the racism of people in
power then at least is an argument right
the idea that you can't be racist at all
if you're if you're black because black
people don't have enough power first of
all the idea that black people have no
power in the United States is utterly
crazy
I mean it's utterly crazy well
especially when I was going on more well
Obama was president the Attorney General
was was president yeah we said this
about Baltimore we kept hearing you
Baltimore right were they the riots they
but with a dry 'its and they were saying
well Baltimore PD you know they're
they're cracking down on black people
okay the chief of police was black the
majority of the City Council was black
and Democrat the entire day the the
deputy the district attorney was
prosecuting the case was black the
majority of the police department was
minority the Attorney General of the
United States was black the President of
the United States was black but up here
in the majority of the city of Baltimore
is black
but apparently it's the white guy's
fault like I just at some point you're
gonna have to make your ideas actually
work in concert with reality okay I
can't like do this with you do you ever
step back and look at this trend and
look at what's going on in popular
culture and looking what's going on with
identity politics in this war between
the left and the right and wonder where
it's going I mean how it feels like the
people on the left are completely
emboldened by the fact that you have
this guy in office who has said things
like grab him by the [ __ ] and he lies
all the time and makes fun of people's
plastic surgery and you you think that
having this guy in in this position I
guess in some way emboldened them and
makes them even more convinced the fact
they're right you know fight but put up
the resistance and the huge tag
resistance hashtag resist it's all over
the place
where does this go I think well no place
good I think what's happening and it's
one of the things that I personally am
not a fan of and this goes all the way
back to the Piers Morgan debate that you
mentioned I mean I started off that
debate with Piers Morgan saying to him
you don't get to in tribute intent to me
that I don't have right right you're
standing on the graves of the kids of
Sandy Hook in order to promote your
political agenda implying I don't care
enough about dead kids because I don't
agree with you that is the sweet spot
where a lot of people like to live which
is if we disagree on politics it's
because you're an [ __ ] right it's not
it's not because we disagree on the best
method to get to the goal or we have
different goals is because you're a bad
person and I think that what you're
seeing is with Trump there's an attempt
to cast all of his voters as people who
love all of the things that are bad that
he does and says it's not that they
voted for him because they thought
Hillary Clinton was the worst
presidential candidate in the history of
America which is true right it's they
they voted for him because they liked to
grab him by the p-word stuff right they
voted for him because they like that
he's vulgar and he lies a lot they voted
for him because they are bad people
right there this is why people misread I
think Hillary Clinton's deplorable
speech and the implication was okay
everybody who voted for Trump is a bad
human being they tried this with Romney
too I mean they tried to cast to get
Romney who's whatever you can say about
Mitt Romney Mitt Romney was maybe the
most honorable person ever to run for
the presidency they tried to cast him as
Jill Biden said a guy who wants to put
y'all back in Chains and he said that he
he straps dogs to the top of his car is
an evil man
Stieg i oh yeah this was a big issue as
dogs so there was there was a there's a
story and he was in the Boston Globe
about how like back in 1982 he went on a
family vacation and when they're
traveling he put the dog in a cage and
put the dog on the top of his car and
this is and this was like a big campaign
issue right
remember binders full of women and you
remember in the 47% number exactly he's
mean he hates the poor he hates what the
binders full of women thing was
particularly stupid because the entire
point he was making is that I was trying
to recruit women to my administrations
they bring binders full of female
resumes to me right so I could staff
more women and they turned it into
binders full of woman he's like Hugh
Hefner
yeah Mitt Romney like really so this
attempt to castigate the other side is
really bad and I think that you see some
of that on the right but I think it's
more reactionary I think that the
unearned moral superiority that the left
likes to kind of wallow in I think
that's that's more on the left and on
the right although I think that there is
an attempt by some on the right now in
response to do some of that well it
becomes these sticking points that you
use to win you know and it becomes
something that people repeat over and
over again you know like the deplorable
thing racist sexist bigoted homophobe
yeah it's just I was walking down New
York City down the street right after
Trump won when they were protesting and
there was this guy right next to me
[ __ ] screaming he wasn't even in the
actual parade itself he was like on the
sidewalk but he was screaming Donald
Trump KKK racist sexist anti-gay yeah ed
just boiled it down to this thing but
the best part about it was he saw a
black guy coming towards him and he just
started screaming black lives matter I
just I just I saw him I saw his soul
like in that one move exact shift to
screaming black lives matter when he saw
a black guy yeah there's the
intersectionality for you right you know
you have to know how to appeal to every
racial group on the basis of a
stereotype it could've been Thomas
Sowell they wouldn't have known yeah
it's almost like the the laziness in
having the ability to communicate is one
thing but having the ability to express
a complete thought that covers something
as nuanced in this complex as American
politics in 2017 that's too hard so
let's just yell out Donald Trump
okay and this this ability to like boil
down what's the difference between the
left and the right to like a little
statement is or you know a bucket of
deplorable basket of deplorable whatever
it is you know but binders of women it's
so tempting cuz it's like it's so
powerful that it works you put it on the
back of a bumper sticker and I think
we've also been shaped a little bit by a
look we all we all live in Hollywood I
mean you live in Hollywood I live in
Hollywood that means that and I think
all of America lives in that milieu
because everyone watches TV everybody
watches movies so when we do politics we
tend to see it through the prism of
house of cards or any of the other
political movies you've ever seen and
that means there's a bad guy right
everybody there's a bad guy there's a
villain and the villain house it can't
just be the de villain is somebody who's
incompetent like usually in politics if
somebody is bad sometimes they have a
malevolent point of view that's pretty
rare usually it's somebody who's
misguided they have some bad ideas
usually they're just stupid or
incompetent like this is what I keep
saying to people who oppose Trump like
why are you attributing to him malice
when stupidity would do well you keep
saying that everything Trump is doing is
out of some sort of malicious genius
are we watching the same film like if
you have a problem with Trump it seems I
have a solution for the left by the way
if they if they really hate Trump this
much listen I thought Obama was a crappy
president I have a deal how about we
just minimized the power of Washington
DC and then we don't have to give a crap
who's the President of the United States
you think anybody in 1832 really cared
who the president was he had no impact
on their lives
but now the presidency has this outsized
impact we care about Washington all the
time we treated that mean the truth as
we watch it for fun I mean right now the
last week particularly with Skinner
Moochie you know it's impossible not to
watch it for fun but it's actually kind
of serious business like there are other
world leaders who are actually looking
at this like this impacts my nation for
us we look at it we go well I wonder
what's on TV on tonight's episode of
Trump the series when you say reduce the
power of the president I think there's a
lot of people that would think that
would be a great idea because having one
person has the authority over 300 plus
million people it is kind of ridiculous
at this point time but how would you go
about doing that like what would be the
best way to implement something like
that I mean it really isn't just the
presidency you'd have to reduce the
power of Congress as well I mean you
have to you have to go back to a
federalist based system where localities
and states have more power over over
local issues and the federal government
isn't that powerful because what's
happened basically in the concert
to tional structure the federal
government was never supposed to be
anywhere near the speck right that there
are very certain delegated powers in the
Constitution of the United States that
Congress has and they are very small I
mean it's things like building post
offices and interstate roads and
regulating interstate commerce but the
idea that they could regulate you know
your toilet flushing is just that that's
silly I mean the founders would have
thought that was ridiculous yet you have
a federal government that that's that's
that big so Congress regulates on that
but if you're in Congress the last thing
you want is to be answerable for that so
what you do instead is you drop vague
statutes right you say things like we
hope but we're passing a law that says
that we should fix the environment and
then you kick it over to the executive
branch and the executive branch you know
run by President Trump or President
Obama has a bunch of executive branch
agencies like the EPA and the APA puts
together all these regulations that
you've never seen never heard of you
never elected these people they put
together all the regulations and then
those are the ones that actually govern
your lives so if you're in Congress and
things go bad you say well that's not
what I meant to do I told them do good
stuff and the bureaucrats were not
elected don't have to care so basically
we have everyone kicking the they can to
the other person for purposes of
responsibility the only way this is
going to happen is if the American
people just decide they're sick of the
federal government running all this
stuff and they start actively working to
elect people who want to minimize their
own power which is difficult I mean most
people in power don't want to minimize
their own power yeah that seems almost
impossible it seems like no one who's
worked so hard to get to the top of the
game he's gone truck the other way to do
it is to elect people on the state level
who are pretty zealous about their own
authority right you've seen this from
like Greg Abbott in Texas that every so
often he'll say to the federal
government listen you're telling me to
do something go screw yourselves like
what are you gonna do about it
well Texas is a weird one like they're
almost ready to leave yeah at any point
ready to put a fence up and go [ __ ] you
I mean weren't they for the longest time
they were they were not really a state
right yeah they're still called the
republic of Genesis right yeah I mean
people in Texas I mean it it's a
wonderful state I love that when you
drive through Texas every single store
is called Lone Star yeah you know Lone
Star brewery or Texas this everything is
named after the state like nothing is
really named after the country it's all
named after the state like a lot of
state pride in Texas there's a lot of
State pride maybe more than any place
else I've ever been
yeah well not a lot of state pride in
California because everybody's a
transplant and yeah it's um you know
people who get here and it represents
something that they always wanted you
know some sort of a liberal paradise
where you could get famous for doing
nothing there's some city pride like
there's how enterprise or San Jose pride
but like California pregnant on the
state are idiots
well California is so confused I mean we
have a grizzly bear on our flag but we
don't have crizzley bears we have we
have a team called the Los Angeles
Lakers not awaken them our legs are all
man-made we have to keep pumping water
in because they [ __ ] dry up a river
is just a giant concrete yeah
Raveena yeah is hilarious when when I've
shown people the LA River my tester LA
River they like shut up yeah the LA
River like it just it is la it's a
[ __ ] concrete shitty slide for water
the city is so dirty I mean it's it's
like I've grown up my entire life here I
mean I was born in Burbank grew up in
North Hollywood like this is the Evolet
of my entire life
the first time I realized I liked it is
when I moved to Boston for law school
because at least the weather here is
good yeah but yeah I mean it's gotten so
shabby lately
it's such a shabby city the weather is
amazing but have you ever been to Mexico
City no I've been a couple times for UFC
events I'm not going back because I
would get headaches from the pollution
and them and what Mexico City to me is
is like LA in the future but with zero
respect for the traffic lights what I
mean zero I've never seen anything like
it it's crazy they're very nice people
everybody's worried about getting
kidnapped over there
I find Mexican people to be some of the
nicest people and real friendly and easy
to get along with but they don't give a
[ __ ] about traffic lights when we were
stuck in traffic look there's
bumper-to-bumper and two green like
going this way cars just go in front of
you and they just sort of make their way
through and people hit the brakes and
they make their way through the
intersection it's a straight up red
light and they just go and it's not just
one one guy goes and another guy goes
behind them and then you got like 20
cars and and it's just gridlock yes but
it's actually indicative of why the
United States works that people actually
follow traffic
it's like it's true in Italy also it's
true in Israel like when I visited
Israel with my wife when we got married
like no one pays attention to the
traffic rules everyone's honking their
horns at each other I'm American so why
are these people so rude all the time
that's like honk the horn she's really
but it is why in America because we have
a baseline and this is what I think is
breaking down actually so not to get too
deep on a point about Mexican city
traffic but I think that you know the
country was based on this idea there's a
social fabric we all have respect for
each other enough that we're gonna
follow the basic rules of the game and
that's true as far as traffic lights
it's true as far as financial dealings
with one another and when you lose that
when you lose the basic respect for the
guy who lives next to you you know you
need to get through the red light you
know screw him it doesn't matter if it's
red then it's kind of indicative of a
culture in collapse generally when small
rules start to go broken like in Italy
the problem in Italy is that 50% of
their economy is black market because
they have high tax rates and no one pays
them you're starting to that in
California too California is the highest
taxes in the country by far we also have
the number-one rate of deductions so we
pass all these high taxes so we can you
know congratulate ourselves for social
justice and then we avoid all the taxes
as much as we possibly can to want to
pull for the accountants yeah exactly
those people are making a freaking
fortune well I just also feel like when
you get a giant number of people smashed
into a small area and with la it's not
even a small area it includes Greater
Orange County and it goes into the
Conejo Valley and it's just like there's
so many of us there's so again it's it's
almost like you get that sort of
diffusion of responsibility thing where
there's just too many people to care
about and you lose this feeling of value
that you have for fellow people I lived
in Boulder for a little while and when I
lived there the People's Republic of
Boulder you want to talk about lefties
oh yeah holy [ __ ] if you have a if you
had a right wing anything on your lawn
like a sign for someone running for they
would take it down they literally take
things down but when I was there I was
amazing how many people are polite when
they drive and they wave and like
there's only a hundred thousand people
exactly so that I was gonna say I'm
looking it up while we're sitting here
it's like 110,000 people in there and
the population of LA County is 10
million people it's it's plus Mexicans
you gotta count Mexicans and then you
gotta count everybody's
- connected to all the other counties
around it's not like there's some border
yeah let's drive around that's exactly
right so it's it is the first time I
visited Oklahoma I had this you know I
was in Oklahoma for doing a radio show
California will be about twenty three
point seven seven million yeah sorry go
away yeah I'm in Oklahoma and I'm
walking down the street and the first
thing that and and just some lady and I
catch eyes now in LA you're from LA you
look away right you're only gonna
stabbed you know that if you catch eyes
with somebody you meet it's rude you
don't catch eyes with people in LA and
among the street we catch eyes that he
goes how are you I called my father I
was like what the where am i what's
going on here like this is not regular
but I do think that there is something
to the idea that if you have too many
people in too small of space well we're
all up in each other's business so much
that it's very hard to say to people
okay
Liberty stay away from one another leave
each other alone it's like yeah but he
lives next door and he's a jackass hate
that guy
cuz he's like right next to you run
Oklahoma the guy next to yous three
miles down the hook there's that and
there's also it's been replicated in rat
population density studies that you get
more mental illness you get more weird
aggressive behavior when they stack rats
and these cubicles and then just jam
them closer and closer together and
that's exactly what's happening with
people to what Manhattan is famous for
it I mean I I enjoy visiting Manhattan
and every time I'm there I'm always like
no I can't I can't right here oh yes too
many humans there last week and I like
the sky so you can't actually see the
sky in Manhattan right I mean you see
the brick buildings and you know 25
stories high and I noticed that we were
walking back to past a store and there
was a shirt on sale and the shirts
entire text was fu you effing eff and I
thought only in New York could you sell
this right I mean try to take this
anywhere else and people would've been
like wait what now but in New York I'm
sure that's a best-seller that's why
honestly I think it's one of the reasons
why Trump won is because he's basically
just a guy from New York he's like a
taxi driver from New York who's really
really wealthy and you know he does what
a taxi driver from New York would do if
you're really really wealthy he marries
models and builds gold toilets and all
this kind of stuff and people in the
rest of the country actually take that
language seriously so when he says stuff
like yeah we're gonna bomb the [ __ ] out
of him you know people in New York like
he has so he do you know and people in
Oklahoma like wow he's serious
it's actually gonna happen and I think
probably not probably this just have
people from kind of talked we saw this
last week right he's talking about the
cops and he was saying this thing at
hover in her hands he's talking like a
Long Island or you know he's talking
about like you know the they throw in
the back of the paddy wagon and we do
all the in and you don't put your head
on that it's fine he they bump their
head they just Mick Holtzman and so the
entire meeting wouldn't know how dare he
he's talking about how cops should rough
people up listen is it appropriate for
the President of the United States to
talk like that about treatment of
suspects no is are we supposed take this
super seriously like this is like Trump
is actually recommending a policy change
with linearity in the room hey that's
what he does he works the room he's a
he's a New York real estate guy who
works the room and more than anything
else if you understand New York and you
understand LA you understand Trump he's
not a giant mystery right he's just any
other reality TV star he's a reality
he's a marketing image guy I mean that's
what he does like he's not even that
great at real estate he puts his name on
the site he brands himself he puts his
name on the side of buildings they pay
him not to be involved in the real
estate business so they can put Trump on
the side of his hotels great I mean
that's what he does that's why I'm kind
of shocked that he's kind of crappy at
the imaging as far as being a president
you'd imagine that he'd be better at
this part of it at least I just think he
didn't understand the volume of hate
that was gonna come his way and I think
he's such an egomaniac he has a hard
time dealing with it like separating and
that's one of the things that I've read
about him that he's getting better at
getting away from the comments and not
reading comments on Twitter but he
[ __ ] blocks people yes yes may suit
him yeah well there's people a group of
people suing them and now they're
actually starting to rule against public
officials people who are in the public
light being able to block citizens that
in having their own opinion about what
this person doing or not doing so then
you have to say well are you allowed to
be vulgar towards the president I mean
how far does that go I mean what are you
allowed to say I mean maybe you should
be able to a whatever the hell you want
about anybody but it chance threatened
I'm late but it's it does go more to the
the level of pettiness he's the most
powerful man on the planet when I was
busy blocking people on Twitter at 3
o'clock in the morning
well ghetto Scarborough and what is her
name Mika Brzezinski
that was just what he says name he was
saying that she should this is the
[ __ ] president he's saying she showed
up with bloody scar
she was bleeding from her recent
facelift exactly and it's it first of
all it turns out that it probably wasn't
true but second it wasn't true I mean it
[ __ ] goes out when you're bleeding it I
agree with you I agree with you but it's
it and and but this ever piece about a
National Review about this you know you
say that the level of hatred directed
toward Trump is warping Trump I think
that it's also warping some people on my
side of the aisle who are who are so you
know interested in the fight that
they're less interested in advancing the
policies that I'd like to see achieve so
I think there's a whole group of people
where let's say that Trump would just
resign tomorrow he'd say you know what
I've had it screw it I'm out and Mike
Pence becomes president and then Mike
Pence proceeds to do all the things
conservatives want him to do you know
you get tax reform and we limit
immigration and we do all of these
things but but he does not tweet about
Mika Brzezinski bloody face I think
there's a whole group of people on there
I'd be pissed
they'd miss it yeah I think that right I
think listening now cuz it's fun what
exactly what they want is somebody who
pisses off the left more than beats the
left right this is them off if you piss
off the left I think Obama sort of
trolled some of the right into insanity
I think there are a lot of people on our
side whereas like this jerk he just he
keeps saying things just to piss us off
and Obama did do some of that and so
Trump is kind of a Twitter troll and so
he does the same thing we're like yeah
that's awesome like two days ago Trump
or yesterday there was a report that
Trump said that he thinks the White
House is shabby now I can say is
somebody on the conservative right my
entire life if Obama said that we would
not let him forget that for 1,000 years
that the White House is shabby I mean
it's like it's an ass move to say that
the people's house is [ __ ] first of all
two mansion right like in second of all
this is the most iconic building on the
face of the planet yeah oh it's shabby
how much at what was he saying about he
said he they were asked him why he that
says visits his golf courses so much and
he said oh because because because my
golf courses are nicer because the White
House is shabby and and but there are
people on the right who are like fine
it's funny like you know at least he's
trolling the left at least it's ticking
them off and say guys ticking off the
left is not a substitute for defeating
the left if you actually care about the
feeding the left like this is one of the
things that drives me nuts because my
you know what my life goal has been to
promulgate particular ideas not just to
piss off the left but I think that in
the fight there are a lot of people who
have fallen into the trap of thinking
these two things are identical right you
pissed off the left that means you're
winning there's like no pissing off the
left maybe part of it
but that's not how you win you wouldn't
by saying things that are true and if
they get pissed they get pissed well my
good friend bill bird did this piece
about Obama back when Obama was mocking
Trump and saying the one thing that I am
that you'll never be is the president
United States the crowd went nuts yeah
remember when he did and Obama was
saying this on stage and you see Trump
in the audience boiling with his you
know big frog double chin you're sitting
there eating it all and that [ __ ]
stuck in his craw there's there's a
whole story that came out from BuzzFeed
about his interaction with a guy named
McKay Coppins a reporter for BuzzFeed in
which McKay was basically like saying to
Trump like you're a joke you're not
gonna run I I think Trump ran just just
because he was sick of people telling
him that he wasn't gonna be President so
yeah I really think that's that's half
of what drives him that doesn't mean
that he can't do good things I hope he
does do good things he's the president I
want every president to do things I like
but you know he's gonna have to get it
under control a little bit because I
mean he was willing to keep the mooch I
mean the mooch the boots was only ousted
because of John Kelly and the mooches
was it what did the mooch say what was
his was about why would he think that he
could say that once he's in the office I
mean first of all I would see Ben and
could even possibly do that I mean ban
is not that flexible I know Steve that's
not that's not something skills
repertoire a giant unit but it doesn't
matter just the idea that he would think
I mean it's guy he must be emboldened by
the fact that Trump has had so many
outrageous things well I mean the
reports from the New York Post that that
he actually the Trump liked it that all
that happened is that there was so much
blowback that he had to replace Kelly
you know puts Kelly in there and Kelly's
like you can't do this right and Trump's
like okay fine but doesn't it seem more
crazy to fire a guy after ten days and
it does to sit him down and say hey man
don't say that again right let's move
forward that's what they should have
done the next day but the problem is
he'd been doing it for a week at that
point right he was out there like saying
that Reince Priebus was leaking on the
president was an enemy of the president
for a week and he was saying that he was
going to get him fired right
and at the same time remember this is
the same week that Trump himself is
tweeting out that attorney General
Sessions who is his most loyal supporter
for a year and a half that that guy's
like a traitor right and that he wishes
he would go away cuz he recused himself
yeah first of all Trump can fire any of
these people at any time like this is
very passive-aggressive
a guy who made his living saying you're
fired on TV it's amazing that all the
people the Trump has fire had been fired
actually through surrogates yeah Mike
Flynn resigned James Comey was fired
basically threw rod Rosenstein and
sessions and then Rosenstein had to
recuse himself which is how you get the
special counsel and Comey found out on
television on TV right here emissary to
go to LA and and give him a letter and
like everyone he fires has to be fired
in the most roundabout I think that
Trump actually this I think the dirty
little secret is I'm not sure Trump
actually likes firing people and I think
I think he I think he kind of like
toward any kind of like torturing people
but I'm not sure that he actually likes
firing them well maybe he doesn't like
people being mad at him face-to-face I
think that he wants them to love him in
front of his face so like when he's not
there you know he can make a phone call
fire him Jetson hang up the phone you
don't have to actually see the guy he
wants that guy to like him yeah I don't
the Comey thing was really bizarre
because it was like oh you can do that
like you this this guy is looking into
improprieties and you can just say no
you can't do that anymore you're fired
you can't look into the things I've done
wrong yeah it was a well the way he did
it was the stupid part so I was calling
for common to be fired since last year I
thought the way he handle the whole
Hillary thing from beginning to end was
terrible and I thought that Trump should
have replaced him before he became you
know as basically day one here's my new
cabinet call me he did a great job you
know uh sure him out the door
bringing somebody new he kept him around
and then the first thing he said to
Comey you remember was when he met him
he said you're more famous than I am
well when Trump says that to you it's
the writing on the wall right there
first of all it's not true but second of
all I think maybe there was also a part
of the problem was that commis a giant
yes no chump come easy six eight six
nine years giant dude towered over thing
is such a comedy and Comey saying he was
trying to hide in the curtains to avoid
Trump they just see Herman Munster over
there hiding in the it's now what did
you join the show I mean it's it's wild
if I didn't think that nuclear war was a
possibility to probably join more but if
I see a [ __ ] Korean missile headed
our way I'm gonna be pissed when Comey
was handling the email thing what
specifically did you not like about it
what I thought it was was crazy was when
he restarted or reopened the case
because of whom having used her cleaner
with wieners all that stuff is like
that's not enough like that seems crazy
the the deleting the emails to me seemed
like I had Mike Baker on from the CIA
and he said essentially anyone else
would be in jail for what she did sure
for sure sure well Comey that this is so
he screwed it up and then he Reese crude
it up so when he originally said
publicly we're not gonna prosecute
Hillary Clinton he was doing something
he didn't have the authority to do the
FBI does not decide whether to prosecute
people they refer the information to the
DOJ and then the DOJ decides whether to
prosecute people it was attorney general
Loretta Lynch's decision whether to
prosecute or not the statute itself
mammal lawyer the statute itself did not
say do you have intent to commit
espionage you have intent to to make
classified secrets public or expose them
to the possibility of being made public
intent is not an element of the crime
right if you do it it's a crime so my
wife as it is a doctor and that means
that she is under HIPAA requirements
there's no elements under HIPAA that
says that if she reveals somebody's you
know proprietary medical information by
accident well there's no intent so she's
okay that's not part of the statute if
she brings somebody's medical records
out to her car and somebody steals the
medical records you know she's working
at the VA or something that's a crime
doesn't matter if she intended to do it
and just left it in her purse so Comey
read the elements of intent into the
crime to get Hillary off and then he
said okay we're not gonna prosecute this
we're gonna leave it alone he shouldn't
have intervene in the first place
remember he made an entire case
basically for why she should be
prosecuted and then at the end he goes
but were you no but no we're not gonna
do that
he also said we're gonna keep Congress
updated on any future development well
you got October and there's a future
development they found this laptop with
all sorts of information on it with new
emails from Hillary Clinton they haven't
seen before
and now he has an obligation to inform
Congress because he told them that he
would and so he screws the pooch again
because he's afraid that if he doesn't
reveal that information Hillary goes on
to win and then it comes out there's
something criminal then people are going
to blame him for Hillary winning and
putting a criminal in the White House
Sin City - oh well I'll be fully
transparent I have to honor my
institution I'm gonna put this out there
of course then Hillary loses and now he
screwed up twice and then he gets into
the White House and now he's supposed to
be
investigating the Trump Russia stuff at
the same time so now he's investigating
basically both candidates in the 2016
election he handled this the wrong way
every step of the way because he was so
focused on what will uphold the in the
integrity of the FBI and the integrity
of the investigations and the integrity
of the DOJ he was less worried about
okay what do I actually have to do under
the law what's my obligation under the
law his obligation under the law is to
shut his piehole hand the information
over to Lynch if Lynch wanted to kill
the investigation let her do it so in a
sense Trump was right and saying that
he's a grandstander yeah for sure I mean
I think that part was right but the
problem remember was not the firing of
Comey it was that two days after he
fired Comey
he went to Lester Holt on NBC and he
said the reason I fired call me was not
all the excuses I gave about the the
Hillary stuff it's because of the Russia
stuff I was angry about how he's
handling Russia I mean that's really
stupid
yeah that's intensely stupid it's
intensely stupid but it's also strange
that it didn't go anywhere right like
that was it like that that's against the
law well it's so it's you know
observation so obstruction looking at
the statutes obstruction is a little bit
more than that so you have to actually
obstruct an ongoing investigation into
criminal activity there's a
counterintelligence investigation going
on but not necessarily a criminal one so
not to get too specific about it but you
should get specific about it yeah I mean
the obstruction laws I mean I've looked
into kind of the statutes that they've
used to suggest obstruction and it's not
clear that there's any statute that
specifically governs something like this
plus it is true that Trump does have the
power as the chief executive to fire as
the commander-in-chief to fire the FBI
director for any reason he chooses now
all that said he can be impeached for
any reason criminal or non criminal
right impeachment is not a you don't
actually have to have committed a crime
to be impeached most people don't even
understand when impeach means they think
that some are another impeach means you
kicked out of office right
that's not right it is there's the house
and they have to vote to impeach you and
then there's the Senate they have to
vote by a two-thirds majority or sixty
yeah I think it's two-thirds majority to
actually convict you of a set of crimes
that they come up with but these are all
political definitions right when it says
high crimes and misdemeanors it doesn't
mean they actually have to prosecute you
like they would in a criminal court and
you'd have to go to jail or any of that
kind of stuff like they could impeach
anybody at any time Clinton didn't even
have to commit perjury if they didn't
want if they wanted to you know impeach
him they could they could have impeach
every president you can impeach it's
just a vote it's just a vote so all the
talk about what's criminal and what's
not criminal the problem for Trump there
are two ways of reading Trump's behavior
in the whole Russia thing right way one
is he's got something to hide that's the
most obvious way he's got something to
hide
that's why he gets her to Flynn we don't
know why he got rid of Flynn he gets rid
of Comey we don't really know why he got
rid of Comey and then brags to the
Russians that it's a pressure off him on
the Russia stuff yeah so the way one is
he's hiding something and now he's
firing everybody who gets in the way and
there's you know the chain of evidence
doesn't not fit that I mean you know the
people he's angry at in order are
attorney General Sessions the Deputy
Attorney General Rod Rosenstein the
former head of the FBI James Comey the
acting head of the FBI McCabe and and
the special prosecutor right robert
muller so those are all people involved
with russia those are the only people
he's really angry at so there's
something to be said for the idea that
maybe he's trying to hide something on
the other hand we haven't actually seen
any hard evidence of collusion itself so
we saw an attempt to collude by Donald
Trump jr. but we haven't actually seen
any evidence that the Russians were
providing special information to the
Trump administration which was then
being weaponized for use in the campaign
we haven't seen any of that stuff so
here's the other plausible theory and
this goes to Trump's personality he's so
petty and he wants to be loved so much
that he is angry that people keep saying
he run because he won because of the
Russians and so now every time people
say that he just gets pissed and he
fires people so call me I mean this is
totally plausible right Comey comes to
him and has said privately that you are
not under investigation and Trump says
Tim well why don't you just say that and
Comey says well I can't say that cuz if
I say that I'm gonna have to update
Congress if you do fall under
investigation and Trump doesn't like
that he wants the public to know he's
free and clear she fires Comey
and then he goes up public and he says I
didn't like how he was handling the
Russia thing I'm innocent why will these
people leave me alone right so he is so
there's two ways to read this either
he's totally innocent but stupid or he's
trying to hide something those are the
only two plausible ways of reading the
situation the Donald Trump jr. thing was
really bizarre because he released all
the emails like I just yeah it's like
look I've got nothing to hide like you
aren't supposed to do any of these
things you're saying in these emails yes
that was not a good moment for for Trump
jr. do you think he got I mean and then
you hear that he was coached by his dad
again you know
this is none of this is good stuff I
think that Donald Trump jr. releasing
the first of all it is imperative to
note eight minutes later the New York
Times released basically the email
change right so he was meeting he's
beating out of the gate and so he puts
that out there which is a smart move I
mean it would be smart if you it would
be smart if he had found a way to spin
it right right like have you done it if
you don't this is the thing in politics
now the way politics works now is your
smartest move if there's dirt about you
is to be the first person out the gate
with it and you put a spin on it right
so like Barack Obama imagine if Obama
hadn't said anything in 2008 and then we
found out a week before the election
that he did coke in high school now a
lot of people wouldn't care a lot of
people would write in 2000 george w bush
was hit with a DUI charge from 1973 and
it probably lost him a point in the
polls
so what obama did is he wrote an entire
memoir and he just kind of dismissed it
right in the middle of the memoir he
goes you know when i was in high school
did a little blow no problem it'll blow
everybody and everyone oh okay did a
little blow alright you know cool so if
you're going to release this kind of
stuff you have to put a spin on it
trump turn your didn't you just put out
the emails and the emails themselves
contain the damning material right it
says right in there right you know
there's a russian government lawyer the
russian government sees this as part of
its effort to aid mr. Trump's campaign
and Donald juniors like thumbs up guys
like I love it sounds awesome right
and so that does not look good it's not
quite as much as you know people on the
Left want to say it is meaning that
there's no evidence yet that any
information was actually exchanged with
the Russians or that anything came of
the meeting most of the people in the
meeting who've said something and said
nothing came of it you know but we don't
know whether Trump knew about the
meeting I find it kind of hard to
believe he didn't you know considering
every major campaign figure was there
but but you know then then they then
they just keep lying and this is this is
the part that's proud that's a problem
are they lying because they just think
they can get away with it and they're
stupid or are they long because they're
actually being meticulous about their
lies yeah I tend to think the former
because this isn't a professional
administration I think these I think
Trump you know fibs a lot he says things
that I mean like on stupid things he
says things like the leader of the Boy
Scouts called me and told me that he
loved my speech ever
and then leader of the Boy Scouts like
what so if so is that a calculated lie
to hide something or is it just the
Trump lies by nature and so he does it a
lot well I think he's just so used to
putting that that spin on things that
publicity spin right
and the thing that he said about this
was that this is what politics does what
happens in politics you get dirt about
your enemy and people exchange
information it's just what happens it's
just you're seeing it now so a lot of
people like yeah well that makes sense
right and this is something that again I
think that we're shaped by Hollywood a
little bit politics is dirty but some of
this stuff is not usual right it's
actually not particularly usual to meet
with a government that is really not
friendly to the United States to receive
information about your political
opponents but if you've watched house of
cards you think well I mean it's like
two steps down from throwing somebody
under the subways I don't because I work
in politics when I go home at night the
last thing I want to do is watch and
read about politics now watch Game of
Thrones that's as political as a guest
yeah house of cards is a great show but
if it's half right like I always wonder
the thing the thing that gets me is when
people suicide themselves that are on
the way to trial I'm like okay I don't
want to be that [ __ ] guy I don't want
to be that tinfoil hat guy but how many
people are gonna suicide themselves I
mean for sure
someone's been murdered somewhere along
the line someone knew something some
powerful people got to them and they
murder them it's gonna happen it has
happened it must have have I mean I
think it happens a lot in Russia I don't
think that I don't believe what Trump
said and again I think this is what
Trump has a skewed vision of what
politics is and because he thinks that
the outer limit of politics is Russia
he thinks anything inside that limit is
now okay but do you think it's ever
happen in the United States or just in
Russia like political assassinations I
can't name a specific example of where
it has I think that that was you open to
the possibility I'm open to the I mean
if someone shows me and Johnson Lynda
John I don't think Lyndon Johnson
wackadoo Kennedy I don't think the
Kennedy whack anybody about Hillary
I don't think Hillary whack any fired up
fired my last thousand bucks I'd be
super tempted to bet on black have you
super tempted to go you know what I
think she went dark a few people let's
see what we got here like you wanna see
white water I'd want to see Vince Foster
I want to see that Enron guy who shot
himself in the head twice you what if I
could if I could really if I could you
know
man I think it's happened I just don't
know I'm sure it's happened at some
point but again if I don't know them and
when I'm hesitant to like why I think
that we and I think that we tend to
think things are regular when they are
they never really irregular Yeah right
so we tend to think that this stuff is
happening like every day and that's why
you see Trump on TV saying well Putin
like America hasn't killed people and
it's like well no not quite like Putin I
mean like Putin legitimately murders his
journalistic enemies yes like I haven't
seen you trying to DoubleTap Jake Tapper
so I'm pretty sure I'm sure no it's not
a regular thing around here even Obama
wasn't trying to like kill Chris Wallace
right but maybe they you know maybe well
Putin is obviously the extreme example
right well obviously the extreme example
is the North Korea but Putin is in that
range
like totally feared essentially a
dictator who's I mean they're a bunch of
Omer I mean Iran and Turkey Maduro a
song yeah Assad Maduro now in Venezuela
who's literally oh like a complete
dictatorship and this is very recently
right but America is a I mean would you
believe it if I said like leaders in
France had people regularly whacked I'd
find it a little bit hard to believe I
don't think we're significantly worse
than France and the whacking people in
politics business I don't think
regularly but I think every now and then
the move is I'm open to the possibility
but I'd have to see the evidence the
lawyer and me well I don't think we're a
house of cards I don't think it's gets
that ridiculous but the point I'm making
is if you think that's a regular thing
if you think that it's not like a rare
thing and maybe once in a while you know
once every 20 years somebody gets
whacked quietly for political reason if
you think that's like a regular thing
then fibbing is like way inside the line
right right like you you hiding
documents is really or you like writing
your son's stupid statement about a
stupid email exchange and then fibbing
about it publicly like that's really
inside the line so again I don't think
that I think some of this I have a rule
about the Trump administration I never
attribute to malevolence what I can
attribute to stupidity because I think
that that's more likely to be the case
it's like the Occam's razor of the
trumpet ministry that is a smart way to
think but I think sometimes malevolence
is real
like I'd like member the Gary Condit
Chandra Levy thing yeah that was weird
that was a weird one where people don't
know the story this guy was having an
affair the girl turned up dead
and then 9/11 happened right away
afterwards so people kind of forgot
about it but they they found her body in
the park and everybody was like Jesus
Christ like this is a woman that was
about to testify that she was having an
affair with this guy and that one was a
good one yeah in terms not not good one
obviously a terrible ones I think so let
me say this I think that you know if
there's murder in politics it'll
probably tend to fall more into the
personal than the political mmm-hmm
it'll probably fall less in terms of
like I have a political vendetta against
this guy and I'm gonna kill him we
haven't really done much of that since
Alexander Hamilton and burr but it's it
but there are eminent listened Teddy
Kennedy left a woman in the back of his
car and a body of water so right drunk
driving right that was the thing with
him he just didn't want to be
responsible for something horrible that
he did very similar to Dick Cheney not
meeting with the police to feel like
something like 18 hours after he shot
his friend in the face yeah I mean I
don't think he was trying to assassinate
his friend drunk hunting and that's
can't rule that one out so yeah but
honestly I'll find Teddy Kennedy a
little more suspicious you leave the
woman in the back of the car swim out of
the car going to a house
sleep come back the next day and my god
she's dead yeah well yeah it turns out
when you leave somebody underwater for
12 hours they tend to do that yeah
that's weird how that works well unless
he was so drunk that he didn't know what
he was doing which can happen you can
get blackout drunk I'm gonna wake up and
going wait a minute did I crash my car
so I don't drink that heavily is that
really a thing like you climbing out the
window the card swim out to the river
bank go to somebody's house come back
like a day later like oh [ __ ] there was
a girl in the back seat I've never had
it happen but I have I've had what I
would call slideshow nights you know
where I get hammered and then like I
wake up in the morning with a pounding
headache and and I just just have these
flashes in my head like who is that
person
like where was I where were we oh yeah
there was that and then that you eaten
breakfast with your friends ago you
remember that thing and you go oh yeah
Jesus
necessarily blackout like I did
something horrible and I completely
forgot about it but I forgot a lot of it
okay but some people I have a friend and
he goes gerbil eyes there's
which that goes off three or four shots
in and he's gone and he's not there
anymore
he almost kind of like nerf the world
around him protect him and get him in
his bed
and he wakes up in the morning he
doesn't know a thing doesn't know a
thing about what happened and it's
really bizarre
it's a terrible things Tim well he's now
we're nice to him but your your instinct
is to get the [ __ ] away from him he just
let horrible things happen but the
stories are legendary but he does he
gets shark eyes he gets he's black like
soulless eyes where he's gone
and you go oh no he's gone yeah it's
weird but I wonder what that is I feel
like that's a neurological issue I feel
like if alcohol does that to you there's
probably like some switches that aren't
connected right in the head I'd imagine
there's something going on yeah mmm yeah
so Teddy Kennedy who knows I mean he was
obviously a raging alcoholic and that
could have been a part of the problem I
mean literally might have gone home not
even knowing that he killed somebody I
mean that'd have to be his only defense
yeah you'd imagine well that was one of
the things that they said they would
have used as a defense again with OJ
that OJ with the CTE that he might not
have even known what he was doing and he
might have flown into some blackout rage
that note an amazing defense like I
would like to hear that like everyone
who has CTE now gets to like run around
chopping up their ex-wife and randos who
end up at their house that'd be a hell
of a defense total at the Twinkie
defense right yeah well the Twinkie
defense was hilarious but there are
people that think that you know there's
you're gonna see more and more things
like that out of former NFL players with
massive brain trauma issues it's
actually a serious legal question you
know like that there's always was a
couple weeks ago this kid he doesn't
even know he did this oh god oh wow
former NFL player Devon hall accused of
killing his mother he doesn't remember
in jail right not doesn't recall yeah
well that's real it's reason yeah I
don't find that wildly implausible I
mean the fact is that we have an
insanity defense and what it means is
you don't know right from wrong well if
you know what you're doing like it this
is something to teach in law school if
you're sleepwalking you kill somebody
and there's no motive so it's difficult
to like you need mental treatment but it
you should be in jail for that not not
really
cases where people are like sleepwalking
and they think that in their dreaming at
the same time so they think that their
wife is actually like the this defense
has been used where they think the wife
is some sort of monster in the room so
they like clubbed her to death and then
they wake up and like oh that was my
wife it's a really creative defense or
it's true any one of the two so well if
we know that people can go crazy and we
know that brain trauma is a real issue
mm-hmm the two of them together I mean
there's something about getting knocked
around in the head where it's so
completely unpredictable and then you
add in this impulsive nature of their
behavior that happens there's something
really weird about a brain trauma it
causes a lot of very strange impulsive
behavior in people they really can't
understand even why they're behaving the
way they're behaving MMH it's not good
obviously this is way off track from
politics to brain trauma you don't want
a former NFL player being the [ __ ]
president and shuts they the CTE study
there was a hundred and eleven players
and a hundred and ten of them had CTE I
mean then you tell me I mean you have
more experience at this I mean I didn't
find that shocking at all I mean they've
been calling people punch-drunk since
yeah 1910 so we'll see the thing is when
you get to that when you get to the
slurring your words part you're so gone
like you're already gone there's a lot
of people that have CTE that speak
really well and they're very articulate
and they're very reasonable and you
wouldn't even understand that they're
dealing with all these this host of
neurological issues the by the time your
avoid obviously I'm not a neurologist
but by the time is it's been explained
to me your voice is slurring and you're
dealing with like real heavy-duty
symptoms like you're [ __ ] like you're
so gone like you're you you're you're
way off the deep so here's a weird
question for you I mean what would you
do about it like I think the NFL is
gonna start losing viewers because of us
I think they are I think you're right
and you know I wonder about MMA do you
it's a factor I think there's there's
two things going on
there's the [ __ ] factor where people
like I don't care I want to watch people
get their ass kicked it's fun it's
exciting people love it it's consensual
it's primal yeah and people know what
they're signing up for when they do it
they know the consequences of it and
it's worth a glory to be the guy who do
delivers it versus the guy who receives
it so I think there's that but then
there's also look you know like the
Colin Kaepernick thing I think that
probably costs a lot of ratings for the
NFL yeah there was that poll that came
out that said I think of the 12% of
people who said that they were not
watching NFL games last year 28% of that
12% said that the Kaepernick national
anthem thing was the reason yeah I mean
it's smaller said he's probably
emboldened them they probably liked it
and they wanted to watch it more this
was fascinating about the cultural
breakdown of the country basically white
people hated and black people loved it
this is this is how the polls were
there's like 72 percent of black people
thought it was great and like an equal
percentage of white people thought that
it was just terrible
no which is it which is a fascinating
look at sort of how race relations work
in the country at large is it's actually
one of the reasons I think that ESPN has
been losing ratings like I used to watch
ESPN religiously and now I all I want is
to just watch my sports and not be
bothered with the politics right as I
say I do that during the day there's a
pet peeve of mine that every time I turn
on ESPN I have to lecture about Caitlyn
Jenner or about black lives matter it's
like shut up Caitlyn Jenner hasn't even
been athletically relevant for since
before I was born I was born 1984 well
the Caitlyn Jenner piece when they did
it for ESPN and I don't know if this is
true or not but the word was that her
getting athlete of the year or whatever
the award was she's a hero a hero of the
Year award hero was directly tied to the
exclusive interview with Diane Sawyer
that make sense they sold the two of
them together as a package deal which I
buy a hundred percent if you do her if
you don't come on
where she came from she's a [ __ ]
Kardashian okay
she's a giant Kardashian that's what she
is now notice I'm saying she yeah you're
saying she I would say very politically
correct
yeah I'm not but the video where they
circled her house and she was like
moving in the shadows behind the drapes
did you ever see that no she mean it was
like the first time she was revealing
herself as a woman so they're circling
her house she's this glorious house and
like looks like it's in Malibu or
somewhere well they're circling the
house and it's in the hills with a
helicopter like the filming he's like
[ __ ] high production value [ __ ] this
isn't just like hey you know we met with
Caitlyn at home Caitlyn tell us your
troubles you know like Kristen back the
former Navy SEAL you know right who just
sits down very reasonably and says this
just feels better for me is Who I am
right no no that's
there was like curtains and shadows and
then she starts talking like war wars
but man he's like oh god and then there
was a weird weirdest part where she said
she got surgery but it doesn't make me
any I was it wasn't like I was any less
of a man or less of a woman before the
surgery well this is the case about
gender right well then why get the
surgery that was like this is well there
are there a lot of questions as to the
logic of all of us I call Caitlyn Jenner
she Caitlyn Jenner is a biological man
sorry triggered sorry to break this to
some all the people who listened to your
show Caitlyn Jenner I had a tweet this
week all the people agree with you the
number one retweeted tweet I have ever
had had a hundred and nine tweeted I
think a day ago and has a hundred and
twenty thousand likes and it's it was
there was a headline from CNN that said
transgender man gives birth to translate
one was transgender man assigned the
female sex at birth gives birth to a
healthy baby boy and so I tweeted woman
gives birth to boy
right because it's a woman I mean this
is like that's not a headline I'm sorry
like I'm just because the woman believes
she's a man doesn't make her a man like
biology still exists sex still exists if
you want to say she's a woman who feels
like a man that's fine if you want to
say that and by didn't care if she gets
hormone treatments or if she wants to
have surgery like it's a free country
what the hell you want but when you
start insisting that I you that I just
throw biology out the window I don't
understand why that's any better than I
is a religious person saying every time
you say something you have to mention
God right like I don't have the right to
do that to you like well that's idiotic
are you fascinated by it are you
fascinated by the transgender like the
obsession with it yes that's a good way
of saying it there's a there's not just
a an obsession it's it's compulsory and
it's rabid so I think that there's a
couple of things that are going on
one is that it's it's very dark but I
think that there is an element of like
this is different and we get to we get
to revel in the in the weirdness of it
but we're gonna pretend that it's all
about the civil rights of it right we're
gonna feel like special because we're
cuz we're on their side right we're not
watching Caitlyn Jenner because it's a
curiosity and because it's weird and
entertaining we're doing it because
we're on Caitlyn Jenner's side but we
feel very good so forever yeah right I
mean renee Richards was a trans person
yeah I mean it's happened throughout
history I mean there's there's what was
a reading a couple of days ago about a
Roman like the the there was something
about reports of some trans soldier in
the Roman army you know one thousand
years ago it's got to be if it's if
exist now and it's existed before it was
popular yeah I mean there's got to be a
lot of people that turn trans now just
because it's exciting oh there it is
right there a trans soldier in the
ancient Roman art that wouldn't it
wouldn't it wouldn't be surprising I'm
not shocked no I'm not sure I mean it's
a condition I mean it's the DSM called
it gender identity disorder and then
they called it gender dysphoria it's
it's a condition I mean like dysphoria
and but that in a lot of people's mind
is labeling it somehow are a negative
well I mean it is highly linked to
suicidality there's a forty percent
lifetime suicide rate for people who
have this particular gender disorder
that seems to me not to be like a great
positive whether or not they transition
yeah yeah I mean do what you want to do
but but the idea that that we as an
entire society have to redefine what sex
is and we have to blind ourselves to a
biology is this is something I'm not
willing to do I think that it's actually
damaging the kids particularly I'm more
than willing to call her a she and chain
but you can only change the name once
I'm willing to call Caitlyn Jenner
Caitlyn Jenner I'm not willing to call
Caitlyn Jenner is she because you can't
change her sexting change right you
change her name to whatever you want I
don't care but you can't she Caitlyn
Jenner is not a chicken Caitlyn Jenner
is not a woman
Caitlyn Jenner is a man a biological man
and if a man lost his penis and and you
know in a tragic accident it wouldn't
make him a woman and if he were born
with high doses of estrogen in his
bloodstream
he would also not be a woman right
you're that you were determined by your
chromosomes and there's not even talking
about intersex people like intersex is
an actual status intersex is a
biological status but this nonsense that
if you Joe Rogan decide
tomorrow that you are a woman no
surgeries nor homo no homer and trip
nothing you just tomorrow you wake up
and not not decide but you feel like a
woman then you have always been a woman
we must treat you as a woman you don't
have to change anything about yourself
for us to even determine whether you're
a woman we just like no I'm sorry no I
mean like I had mental illness yeah I
had a grandfather I got I get so much
[ __ ] for this but I had this is not me
being unsympathetic to people who suffer
from a condition that is really tragic
and obviously harms people you know in
terms of again the rates of suicide and
depression are astounding my grandfather
was it was a bipolar schizophrenic and
it would have not been good for him or
my family if people had said to him Nate
you're right the radio is talking to you
Nate you're right the curtains are
talking to you he went that they put him
in a mental hospital they gave him
lithium and then he was better and he
could actually live a normal relatively
happy life there's no good treatment for
gender identity disorder gender
dysphoria whatever you want to call it
but to suggest that it is a condition
that doesn't require treatment there
really it's just that you're actually
bringing female again this is a
scientific there's no scientific
evidence to back this whatsoever
even these studies that have been done
talking about there's a female brain and
a male brain first of all if you say
this to a feminist you're a sexist right
if you say to a feminist there's a
female brain in a male brain and male
brain works differently than the female
brain the feminists are looking like how
dare you well it's also rare times we
are allowed to celebrate classic
definitions of female beauty when a man
embraces him when he becomes a woman
lipstick high heels short skirt this is
like not Caitlyn Jenner was only a woman
when Caitlyn Jenner was on the cover of
Vanity Fair and a bustier right right
but if he had just said listen I look
exactly the same as I did yesterday but
I'm a woman yeah if he got a short
haircut and dressed like Billie Jean
King right it's the reason why the why
the media loves Laverne Cox because
Laverne Cox has had surgeries and looks
a lot like a woman so I don't know who
the guy from well the transgender woman
from Orange is the new black I never
watched that I've never watched that
show either but she's on the cover of
Time magazine
Oh or he's on the cover of Time magazine
well there was the woman in that show
isn't that the one where the girl who
Ruby wrote is that the girl that's
Laverne Cox okay that's a woman or man
that's man it used to be a man it used
to be a man's woman
very tricky no still a man but
transgender so out of the loop
I'm not old man I'm that old man that
headline there right it says America's
next civil rights frontier and that's
the key
you have a bunch of people in the United
States who are suggesting that they want
the next civil rights fight always the
next civil rights fight right yes is it
the civil rights fight is immigration or
the civil rights fight is gay marriage
or the civil rights fight is
transgenders okay how about this how
about there was only one real civil
rights fight it was about black people
who had been historically oppressed in
the United States for 200 years who had
been slaves yes we'd been slaves and
genders this is correct
okay the worst that Caitlyn Jenner had
experienced was being incredibly wealthy
in a high net-worth suburb this is not
to say the transgender people don't you
know aren't discriminated against right
and some in some areas of American life
I'm sure that's true but it's also like
behavior is not the same as being born
black or being born Asian or being born
with you know disabled if if I'm a
business owner and I hire you and you're
a man and you come in the next day and
you're dressed in a woman's clothing
saying you're a woman but you still have
a full beard like I don't see why I as a
business owner I'm expected to eat the
cost of that like that seems bizarre to
me eat the cost is a great way to phrase
it I didn't have a dog in this fight I
didn't I I was completely open and
liberal about it until there was a case
where a man who had been a man for 30
years became a woman for a little less
than two years and then started MMA
fighting women yes exactly exactly
eating the [ __ ] out of these women and
not and not proclaiming that he or she
used to be a man because what in quotes
it was a medical condition that I did
not need to disclose like that's not a
[ __ ] medical condition right and if
you ever watch the fights she's now in
fact yeah yeah she wasn't winning
because she was skillful she was [ __ ]
manhandling these women it was ugly
horse
it was hard it's like this is it but
again it's it's so funny how the
transgender movement destroys the
feminist movement by living off of the
the sort of lies that the feminist
movement promulgated so the feminist
movement said stupid things like women
and men equally athletic proficient well
that's not very repeated very recently
that there's no biological difference in
the genders and it's all
social absolute horseshit I mean I'm
sorry there's there's no scientific
evidence to back that and it's
particularly true with regard to actual
physical capacity this is just nonsense
there's just no scientific evidence but
I'm Alan Turing yeah yeah yeah I mean
mountain of it my favorite study on this
is you know there was remember there's
that those commercials about like
throwing like a girl running like a girl
right there's feminists commercials
saying what is it to be running like a
girl no true an adult woman and she'd be
running all girly and then they would
show a little girl and she's running and
it's still a little girly but she's
running you know like normally it's only
it's not more exactly fierce it's it's
only society that has forced the little
girl to run like woman first of all I
have a three-year-old girl she runs like
a girl
it's not because I'm teaching her that
cause her mom runs because she doesn't
write but she play with dolls because
you're a sexist pig it's because of that
my daughter started off liking trucks
like in the first year and I give a [ __ ]
and then and now she likes playing with
dolls and dressing up in princess
dresses I could care she's a girl she's
always been a girl she'll always be a
girl but if she likes trucks oh I think
that was an issue with one of my
daughters too my daughter was a little
worried about our girl she's gonna be a
dyke
she's like no what's the big deal you
like lesbians who cares I don't care I
do not care and she's like and then she
turned the corner and then she got but
we just let her be whatever she's in but
she was really into like Batman for a
while yeah my daughter is in a band then
she was into one woman like who cares
but is it but but what what's funny
about this is that the left kept saying
even when I met my wife right who's a
conservative and I made her more
conservative when he got married cuz
that's what men tend to do to their
wives but she but she you know we
remember early on we had a conversation
about this and I said women don't throw
like mine and she got like all offended
and I said but that's factually true she
said right but it's but it's insulting
it's like no that's factually true like
I'm sorry like there have been studies
out of a thousand if you took a woman
throwing a baseball and then a thousand
men throwing a baseball the woman will
throw faster than out of those thousand
men this is in the book the sports chain
the woman will throw faster than two of
those men out of a thousand and we're
not talking about like goose Gossage
here we're talking about regular human
we're talking about the accountant from
down the block we're talking about Paul
Ryan flinging a baseball yeah right I
mean that's not the way this stuff works
well that was the counter that Fallon
Fox used was that she actually lost to a
woman she lost her woman named Ashley
Evan Smith but what I said was no this
proves my point is
you're not good you're just a man well
this was you know John McEnroe got
slapped all over the lot when he said
about Serena Williams she's right
Serena was great and all but if Serena
Williams were competing he said she's
the best female player ever and they
were like well why not just the best
player ever is it because she's a woman
like if she were a man she'd get her ass
kicked and everyone was like no how dare
you there is something called the
universal tennis ranking she drank in
the mid ranks of college male players if
she were a man and Serena Williams is
said like five years ago
now I never want to play it like Andy
Roddick he'd kill me she did this there
was a 200th man in the world who she
wanted to just warm up with and they
they played it like just a normal match
for he won six one six nothing right and
he was and he was like ranked 200th in
the world and the only shock was that he
dropped a dropped a point to her well
there was the issue of renee richards
when renee Richard started playing
tennis against women and kicking their
ass and he was a middling player at best
as a woman or as a man rather but as a
woman he was a [ __ ] killer hey I mean
this is what should insult feminists it
turns out the Caitlyn Jenner when all
these hero of the year awards and
everything we men are so great that even
when we decide to be women we're better
than women that was the woman for six
months but he's amazing he's incredible
he's just he was a natural even if being
women than women
no wonder feminists are piss and they
should be and and it this whole glossing
over the the difference between
feminists who have been claiming that
women are distinct from men and
important and different and better in
certain ways like I don't understand how
you hold these two simultaneous thoughts
Hillary Clinton needs to be president
because we need a female president but
also Donald Trump if he said he was a
woman tomorrow would be a woman how do
you hold those two simultaneous thoughts
I always thought that in the last week
of the election of Trump thought he was
gonna lose you should have just declared
himself a woman and then he too could
have fires a woman I'm the best looking
woman ever I've been I've been voted as
the best looking woman of all time the
great arguments that I got in online
when I wasn't even arguments but so many
people were calling me a bigot because
of this Fallon Fox thing goes it was
stunning because it was so confusing to
me I'm like I'm talking about defending
a biological woman like you these
biological women at least two of them
got the [ __ ] beaten out of them
by Fallon Fox before they found out that
she used to be a man I'm like that's not
an issue to these people and so this one
woman said she's always been a woman and
I said okay she gave birth she
impregnated a woman and got her pregnant
I go what about then she goes even then
yeah even then she was a woman she was a
woman she went she was [ __ ] a woman
with her dick and getting that woman
pregnant like we are in Fantasyland
it's it's it's crazy town so this
doesn't mean this is what's crazy like
you can't
just because something's illogical you
can't just decide it someone's a bigot
like that you're you you were in a weird
area we're talking about bone structure
and here's the crazy density there there
there's a crazy thing is that they
always rely on these gender reassignment
doctors to define the terms and it's
really interesting because I got deep
deep deep into the rabbit hole with this
because I was really shocked at how many
people were angry at me yeah and there
is one doctor who is a board-certified
endocrinologist who sort of broke it
down she's like not only is the science
behind this crazy but when you have
gender reassignment surgery one of the
big issues with men transitioning into
women is bone density who she's like
when you have gender reassignment
surgery you're taking estrogen which
actually preserves bone density she's
like not only do they have less bone
density once they become a woman they
might have more well because you're
preserving it like it's not you're not
gonna automatically be just like a woman
in a year or so
I don't think surgeons I mean I know too
much about doctoring from having spent
1,000 years with my wife's medical
education to believe that doctors have
the capacity to magically change a man
into a woman no maybe it's gonna happen
one day with like CRISPR or something
like that when they start using you know
genetic birth maybe and if you actually
entered the chromosomes before birth but
no I mean like no if it once once you're
didn't once your genes have been defined
once your chromosomes in default like
this is fifth-grade science people its
fifth grade science what scares the [ __ ]
out of me is when you hear these stories
about people deciding that their child
who's like eight or nine years old that
beyond belief it's scary because you can
nine year look a [ __ ] 17 year old
doesn't know that was the thing about
the Ruby Rose girls she was saying that
when she was young when she was a
teenager she wanted
be a man she wanted to be transgender
and that she had gone through that phase
and now she's so happy that she didn't
do anything right well they say that
that eighty percent of kids who
experience any sort of gender dysphoria
as children grow out of it so when you
have a society that reinforces it and
then in Canada they're now having their
passing laws now that say that if a kid
says you know you have a girl and the
girl says I'm a boy and she's three that
the government can come into your house
and take the kid because obviously if
you if you don't want to humor the kid
and get the kid treatment or surgery or
hormone blockers then you're obviously
doing something wrong to the kid this is
just it's insane first of all if anyone
tried to do that with my kid I would
meet him at the door with a gun I mean
that this is this is the kind of stuff
where you're talking legit Civil War
like when you say that the government
can take people's kids from them because
the government knows better than you how
to parent your kids on basic things like
are you a boy or a girl that's gonna get
violent pretty quickly if you send
someone to my door with a gun saying I'm
taking your daughter from you because
your daughter says she's a boy at school
and you and you're not gonna take her to
a psychiatrist to start her
transitioning process
oh no but one how did we get so far down
this rabbit hole of insanity and this is
again this is not taking away the
personal choice of a 60 year old man
like Bruce Jenner who decides he wants
to be a woman you want free country go
have at it have a good time but how did
we get so crazy that that becomes an
option that people aren't they're not
paying attention to the the the massive
variables that a child encounters
psychological variable stress variables
what's going on in the home what's
happening hormonal e what's happening
psychologically what is happening to you
and how how can you decide like this is
it your get you're gonna allow this kid
to make a like a locked-down decision to
begin gender transition surgery at like
9 or 10 years old hormone blockers in
there to an eight-year-old yeah and you
know and then they'll show you like this
girl who's like 13 who used to be a boy
and you know you see her act and talk
and they go how could you imagine that
this isn't a girl okay I don't you know
I don't know I don't I don't know I mean
I just don't know what happened I'm
gonna go with the fact that there's a
y-chromosome in every cell of that
person's body except ironically for some
of his sperms
to tell me that that's probably a boy
and and yes you can block the
manifestation of some physical
characteristics that does not change the
chromosomes and there are legitimately
intersex people right mean they're
people who legitimately have conditions
like Klinefelter's syndrome I mean
they're like these are these are actual
biological things but if you're telling
me any boy can be a girl no no the
answer is no and it's that's that's not
biologically correct and you're not
doing any sort of service to a child
especially we evidence less I mean you
know you're doing no service to a child
by bringing by humoring what is
obviously a mental condition and a
mental condition by the way again linked
forty percent lifetime suicide rate is
higher than any other population on
planet Earth by a whopping margin I mean
telling kids that we are going to force
you into the like you express when
you're five that you think you're the
opposite sex and now at eight we're
gonna transition you into this and your
suicide rate is exactly the same as
somebody who didn't do that railroads
very similar to someone who didn't do
that and and like this is somehow
supposed to benefit the person it's just
it's it's beyond imagination I think
it's cruelty well it's very strange for
sure and as someone who doesn't
experience gender dysphoria I like to
mean i when when someone's got some sort
of an issue whatever it is whether you
call it an issue or a condition or
whatever the [ __ ] it is and I don't have
it I try to be as as standoffish I tried
to be as objective I tried to be as as
kind as possible this is a weird one
though this is a weird one because it's
it's become some sort of a fad and any
criticism of it whatsoever even
discussion of it you are labels as a
transphobic piece of [ __ ] yeah I think
it's only weird honestly because it's
run into the weird sexual politics that
dominates in the country because if we
were to talk about anorexia which is a
form of body dysphoria yes alright or if
we were to talk about I mean they're
actually something body identity
integrity disorder right where people
like want to lose an arm and we would be
saying well the problem is in your brain
it's not in your arm right like chopping
off your arm seems a little extreme but
if you want to do that like go ahead but
if you were a kid and it's in
five-year-old wouldn't say oh well this
kid's gonna suffer with this their
entire life let's just chop off their
arm now let's let's prevent them their
arm from developing like this is not and
to tell the entire society that this is
a positive good is is a whole other
thing it's one thing to try and
people who have a disorder humanely has
another thing to redefine in terms of
the entire civilization as well as
biology in order to fit that this is
it's valuing the subjective over the
object of science is objective your
feelings about who you are is subjective
you can have those feelings but once you
are trying to translate those feelings
into the objective standard we almost
all by now you're encroaching on my
territory it's not just it's not just
you're doing what you want to do anymore
you're telling me what I have to do
that's a different thing
right now when people say that there's
this 40% suicide rate amongst
transgender people one of the arguments
that I've heard is it's because they're
not accepted right I've heard this do
yeah yeah and that if they were accepted
and then they felt themselves and they
felt loved for their true self then it
would be just like everybody else and
I've seen no evidence to suggest that if
there's if there is a decrease based on
treatment then it's marginal at best but
not just for yeah it's is it uniform
like I would like to know like is like
gender dysphoria is it in a similar
percentile as anorexia or what
bodybuilders get or what strippers get
when they get triple left it's like the
anorexic suicide rate I think dysphoria
is a weird thing you know it's it's it
is met people there's a girl that goes
to my yoga class that's anorexic and
it's so disturbing sad oh it's it's
horrifying it's horrifying
and listen I'm not so I'm not saying
that we should mistreat people but if
again you're talking about an entire
society being forced to redefine basic
biological terminology right then like
it'd be an adult like like live with
this I'm happy to treat you with listen
what I would hire a transgender person
but I'm not going to see I'm not going
to change what reality is in order to
humor you like if you call yourself
Napoleon I'm not going to call you
Napoleon or not would you take it into
consideration no I mean when you're
looking at this still it goes what if
someone was really good at their job and
someone else was equally good at their
job but not transgender would you lean
towards the not transgender person
because you say well the transgender
person they're dealing with a host of
psychological issues obviously well I
mean I think that you would have to
think about you know typical aspects of
reliability just the same way you would
with
and their mental disorder if you knew
somebody was was manic-depressive which
is super common and you have somebody
who's equally qualified he's not
manic-depressive you might think well
that might have an effect on how they do
their job yeah so maybe I mean I'd you
know I haven't had enough personal
experience with transgender people to
know whether it would impact a
secretarial job or something probably
not you know probably not but it's but
again to pretend that like transgenders
in the military this seems to me like in
a decision that should be made by
military people will actually have to
determine how much does this impact the
job and if you already have a group of
people with a 40% suicide rate who have
high levels of instant higher levels of
instabilities a group not individually
as a group and you're choosing which
groups to pick from to be on the
frontlines in small units living under
severe pressure for months at a time you
know like is that something that is that
what you're gonna go for or is that
something where like you'd have to
overcome certain presumptions in order
to get there yeah I tweeted something
that Kristin Beck wrote the other day
but when the military band went trump
apparently there was not a real bang
that was [ __ ] I mean base track from
the sessions thing yeah yeah it's later
who's back to 20 my sessions yeah this
was the part about that I didn't like
like I actually agree that there is a
question as to whether the military
should be recruiting transgender people
because I think that the military has
certainly it creates a bunch of
questions not just questions about who
showers with whom but also questions
like okay you have a transgender man
does he have to fill the female
standards of fitness or the male founder
that standards a fitness bra like these
are actual questions yeah does it how
does it work with troop cohesion where
you have a group of men and they have a
man he was technically a man but he's
did you treat him as a woman like does
he have to carry the same amount of
stuff is the guy like how does that work
exactly
does this the cost of gender transition
surgery and hormones and psychologists
like does that come into play at all
here would you recruit from the anorexic
community for the military Mike these
are like real questions but that said
that's why they commissioned to study
from general mattis at Department of
Defense
he was going to look into all of this
and then give a report in six months and
Trump just sort of tweeted it out there
I agree that I think that trumps general
you know his general attitude on it is
probably correct in terms of what the
military's that are doing what what it's
not there to do but what I don't agree
with is how he did it at all because
it's disrespectful to the people in the
military
or transgender I mean like I wouldn't
want to find out in a tweet I don't want
a better rationale than two tweets and
then we're back to and then we're back
to you know like look they're doing more
than I I mean they're suffering the
military I didn't serve in the military
it seems like it would be pretty
hypocritical of me to say well it's
perfectly respectful to say in to tweets
you're out because that's the way it is
without any sort of supporting
argumentation and he didn't actually
implement a policy he didn't give the
policy to the Defense Department so they
could even implement it the Pentagon
says they're not implementing it because
they don't have a policy this is a PR
thing is a weird PR thing but it really
stirred up people in the designed to do
right I'm sure well either that or he
just felt like tweeting I think that's
what I think that's what it was I mean
he wanted to shift the conversation and
it was the funniest thing about that is
that he did it in two tweets and the
first half of the tweet was in
consultation with my generals and my
military experts we have decided that we
will no longer accept ellipses
ten-minute gap transgender people in the
military so there was there was a there
is a story of BuzzFeed that was kind of
funny
they wouldn't interviewed a bunch of
people in the Pentagon and a bunch of
the people in the Pentagon were like
during that 10-minute cab I didn't know
whether we were going to nuclear war
what right is that first we was like
except North Korea's North Korea's
missile missile test program Wow yeah
this again is evidence you know I think
it's an example of even if I think the
policy is good good policy done the
wrong way is actually counterproductive
for the policies that I want to see done
like I want it laid out by mattis I want
it laid out by Defense Department I want
all the reasons laid out so we can have
a good discussion over it I don't really
want just like thought vomit on Twitter
that's just not I don't think it's
effective well it also seems that this
issue is such a hot issue and it's also
an issue that you're not really allowed
to have an opinion on other than the
standard opinion this is always a woman
trapped in a man's body and this is the
way it is and by the way healthy this
day Guardian notion that it's like a man
that it's like the the the soul in the
machine and that's the there was a woman
and deep down for 40 years who had three
children with a man's penis and now is
now is escaping
there's a Ghostbusters like again
have you seen the man in England was it
in England no it was Germany the man
that identifies a six year old girl yes
and so they turned him into a six year
old girl so there's this click yes is
that clip of me that's gone around the
internet a fair bit where I'm talking to
a college girl about this and she's
saying like men or men can be women and
women can be men and I said well how old
are you I love that clip why aren't you
sixty to sixty yeah and she's like
baffled like what and then it finally
hits her and it's like well you know ya
say it's I think this is what's kind of
frightening about the age we live in is
that we can't even come up with common
definitions of basic things how we
supposed have conversations with each
other if you can't decide what a man is
or what a woman is or or whether a
scientific fact ought to be relevant or
not you know like like at least we could
decide what was a scientific fact or not
before and now it's like the subjective
has just eaten everything if I don't
think it's a scientific fact it's no
longer a scientific fact x-parameters of
the argument it's become about freedom
the freedom to be your authentic self
versus biology and right and again be it
be your authentic self I don't give a
[ __ ] they will do whatever you want like
you know yeah more power to you but it
is no longer about your freedom to be
authentic self when you're talking about
either legislation that impacts how I
run my business or hi raise my child or
you are suggesting that it is my duty to
humor your authentic self like I think
there's a lot of people who do stupid
crap their entire lives it's not my job
to humor their authentic self I mean I'm
Pro drug legalization but I've never
done drugs and I think the drugs are
stupid you know that don't tell me that
I have to like cheer when somebody
smokes a joint like do what you want but
don't tell me that I have to redefine
what I think is good and bad behavior
like that's silly yeah it doesn't make
any sense and the other thing that it
became this weird political hot point
where we were talking about bathrooms
yeah then it become like the number one
toss was easy for people to sort of boil
take the argument into that right of
course like this what about my children
my children we go in the bathroom and a
man with a dress is gonna come in he's
gonna claim that he's a identifying as a
woman and it got to the point where so
many people were upset about it that
people were boycotting South Carolina
remember that oh yeah you know that and
this the one I thought was amazing was
was the n-c-double-a
saying they were gonna remove the final
four from North Carolina cuz they passed
the the bathroom bill right in North
Carroll
and I asked online okay so when are you
gonna abolish the separate male and
female divisions of the n-c-double-a
like I mean you've said that we can't
have separate male and female bathrooms
we're biological males play and you know
we're biological males go to one
bathroom and biological females go to
another so why do you have separate
divisions why do you have a whitey of an
NCAA women's division in an NC double-a
men's division
yeah where does this go I mean
eventually it just boiled down I mean
eventually it goes to one place or
another like either we just say this is
a step too far it give me a break you
know science says no or we say anyone
can be anything at anytime a man is a
woman and a woman as a man and you know
it's in just pick have you ever seen any
videos of people that are gender fluid I
have seen those videos those videos are
fascinating they wake up one day and
they're a woman the next day they're our
man and son there was a guy on NPR on
radio lab on the podcast who transitions
at times of stress makes perfect sense
to me in the middle of having a
conversation I just switched I'm Paul
now I'm a man when he's more stressed as
he switched into a woman because that'd
be really sexist right I mean I think
they're like if he was stressed at work
and he switched into a woman and started
crying that seems kind of sexist to me
that's implying that women are the
people who cry at work so that is sex
also this raises a bunch of other weird
questions like okay if you're like
there's there's been this again you want
talk about weird there's been this this
this weird push in parts of the trans
community to suggest that a male who
doesn't want to have sex with a
biological male who says he's a female
is a is now a sexist against foam is it
transphobic you're a man who doesn't
want to have sex with a man a biological
man and it doesn't make you gay to do
that right if you have sex with the
biological man who says it's a woman
that's straight sex but if you were to
have sex with a biological woman who
says she's a man you're gay mmm yeah
weird it's definitely weird but I have
seen the arguments and the blog posts
and the tweets about men who
discriminate against trans women who do
not want to date trans women and people
keep saying well it's it's culturally
defines like no that's called evolution
have a baby together
correct yeah correct it turns out that
evolution wants men to have sex with
women like I'm sorry to break it to
everybody but evolution
relies on you
reproduction okay if you put that thing
in the wrong place it ain't gonna
reproduce like that's just sorry I I
don't know I don't know why I have to
keep apologizing for science and and
then they say that my party is the party
of non science like what like you say
that two minutes before my baby is born
it's not a baby and a man can be a woman
but I'm anti science I'm just I'm wildly
confused by this well the whole thing is
wildly confusing but it's just it's such
a strange subject it's such a strange
subject that's been brought to the phone
I think it's about more than moral
posturing than it is about people who
actually think this is a major issue I
think you're absolutely right and I
think people love to be virtuous they
love to be on that side they left a
virtue signal how dare you yeah how dare
you with dicks or lack of fake dicks but
they don't really have a lot of fake
dicks they don't really go that far
they just sort of take testosterone and
see what's up but it's just it's a it's
a weird facet of our society today that
is uh unexpected I mean you go back
twenty thirty years and it was an oddity
and you know even there during the renee
Richards thing it was it was more of an
oddity than anything this is why I say I
think that it's I think that a lot of
people who are virtually signalling are
still treating it as an oddity they just
won't admit that right I think that
they're watching it because it's a
circus to them and I think that's
actually cruel I don't think that you
should like put people who suffer from
mental illness on the cover of magazines
I just don't I think that that's bad
strategy
what about body builders I mean you know
I don't know that I'll be honest with
you I don't know that much about
bodybuilding
I mean look like I know that more of a
marathon runner what I've heard the
argument about body builders they suffer
from it as well is that in order to get
that big you almost have to have some
sort of a body dysmorphia you have to
not understand how insanely huge you are
yeah I'll be really into it their
argument is they're really into it and
which makes sense to me but I've heard
people say that that it's it's like
we're almost like a reverse anorexia
like they never feel like they're big
enough yeah I've seen that people say
that before yeah well it's weird that
the human mind is suspect or subjects
really variable and it's really open to
suggestion really open to suggestion
there's people above children transition
for sure for sure I mean listen you you
see it in everything including fashion
like how many dudes wax their chest now
30 years ago nobody wax their chest do
they waxing dudes are waxing Jeff shave
their chest wax their chest whenever
whatever it is questions about the youth
or turn to young Jamie yeah but I mean
you watch TV now and every dude on TV
has a chest as bare as my you know 14
month old sons area and it's like where
did this come from and this game was
great then one work chiseled it also
came from TV and was it like TV it was
gonna be men are gonna be hairless now
this is this is the new trend men are
gonna be hairless mmm you don't even get
the Burt Reynolds like you know bare
chest anymore and so if people are
susceptible to even that with regard to
fashion like people will have first for
five years people convince themselves
that skinny jeans or a thing you know
what people are open to virtually any
sort of suggestion bell-bottoms to come
in they come out and when they try to
bring bell-bottoms back I did not a good
coffee they tried and people like nah
not this one platforms when these two
are platform shoes that's what I'm just
keeping around on my dad's old clothes
because eventually they're they're gonna
come back in again you never know yeah
the idea of fashion and culture also
being like the same sort of mechanism
that allows people to be variable when
it comes to their gender and that's I
mean you actually said there's a study I
thought this is chastening there's a
study in Britain or Poland Britain about
sexual orientation and what I found was
95 percent of people over the age of 60
identified as exclusively heterosexual
of people who are under the age of 30
only 42 percent identified as
exclusively heterosexual it was like
okay well in two generations it's not
that half the population became bisexual
right that is not a scientific thing
that means that people are open to
suggestion about their sexual behavior
which you would assume hmm right so so
assuming that culture has no impact and
this goes against the whole you born
this way aspect of even the homosexual
rights movement the gay rights movement
that says oh you were born this way
agree that there's a genetic component
to sexual behavior but the idea that
that's what why 50% of the UK population
has shifted toward you know I'm open to
anything the culture has some thank you
person as I say 95 percent people over
the age of 60 and then 42 percent of
people under the age of 30 so that's it
so that's 42 percent say no okay no 42
percent
we'll say they're extremely extremely a
heterosexual extremely forties
exclusively heterosexual so 60% nearly
60% 68% say that they're on the spectrum
but not exclusively heterosexual that's
fascinating I wonder if they only talk
to women or drunk like young drunk girls
they get crazy like if you think I'm
trying to you know laughing right we're
Adam Adam has a whole shtick about like
in the future there's gonna be a point
where guys are considered gay if they
won't kiss another dood like what are
you gay you afraid that you're gay kiss
another dood and show me you're not gay
we've gone we've gone around the bend a
little bit we have well there's also
this thing that I think happens when you
have two very clear sides you know where
you have teams and you sort of have a
line in the sand you're not supposed to
cross there's the right side and there's
the left side and we have that in this
country we really don't have a third
party option no there are third parties
are kind of a joke and whenever you have
two opposing viewpoints people dig in if
you've seen this new documentary about
William F Buckley and gore Vidal and the
debate is any good it's great it's
really interesting debates they had
during the 1968 election it's
fascinating
we have watched some of those debates
but yeah it's intense yeah particularly
the one where Buckley threatens to punch
fit all because I'm a queer and says
I'll sock you in the face and you'll
stay plastered it's weird because it's
spectacular and it's such like it's so
in the the speak of the day you know the
Brahmin accent it's great like it's
almost British accent yeah it's
fantastic it's really interesting and
then but but the these I mean it's that
thing this my team versus that team and
I think the left is guilty of it as much
as the right is guilty of it it seems
like it's it's a real issue where
there's a lot of people that have ideas
and opinions it's sort of crossed party
lines but they vote on one side or
another and they vote for their team I
think that's right I think that
especially in this last election I think
that was true I think that people felt
so alienated by the other side like to
understand a lot of people who voted
you have to understand that there are a
lot of people in the country who felt
insulted by the left they were just sick
of being called the racist sexist pig at
homophobes every time someone wanted to
advance a policy on the left and so they
said okay screw that at least Trump's
not calling me that bright so I'll do
that and then they're a bunch of people
on the Left who now feel insulted by
Trump's even presence and they think all
the people who voted for Trump are those
people and so they're fighting racism
sexism bigotry and homophobia by voting
against Trump again it would go back to
this day and there there's a hardening
of there's not one bubble in the country
there's two you know the right likes to
accuse the left of being in a bubble in
the coast there's there's a bubble on
the right too which is the idea that
everybody on every piece of the media is
lying to you right there's always fake
news everything is fake news you don't
like it it's fake news these bubbles are
not healthy for the Republic I mean we
can't have conversations with each other
if we if we do this routine no deception
is not healthy across the board and
there's another thing that's going on
where everybody's a Nazi like I've never
heard people called a Nazi more than I
have over the last six months I mean
it's been crazy if you support Trump
you're not see you're a neo-nazi you're
here
somehow or another you're a fascist if
you didn't vote for Hillary you're a
Nazi like we some people have boiled it
down to like the purest form yeah I
agree I mean first of all it
demonstrates tremendous historical
ignorance forget the Holocaust like you
just look at what who Hitler was and the
prophecies he promulgated like he was
basically he was all over the place when
he wanted to talk to socialists he was a
socialist when he wanted to talk to
capitalist he was a capitalist he was he
was a top-down government guy for sure
but he would speak the language of you
know what would be considered the
European far-right today on a lot of a
lot of issues but then he would talk
about redistribution of resources and
universal health care and all this kind
of stuff and removing guns but he's just
a convenient Club I mean that's just a
convenient Club because then and then to
this part that scares me once you say
that somebody is Hitler and then it
actually becomes obligatory to
physically resist them then we can say
you can't have a conversation with
Hitler yeah like once you say somebody's
Hitler the KKK what are you what are you
gonna do let have a conversation with
them at the very least you won't talk
with them and at the most two might try
to punch them that is really a problem
with that those the nomenclature right
that's really a problem with identifying
someone in that way that they
are someone that you have to resist and
they are someone who cannot be reasoned
with they are someone who is absolutely
evil there's no like variables or
variance in their behavior and listen I
like fiery political rhetoric I find it
fun but I think once once you label
somebody you know completely evil you
you you have responsibility not to
debate with him the first one's going
not to talk with them even the
conversation legitimizes them yeah I
mean that like I mean listen I'm sure
you're gonna get a bunch of [ __ ] from
people for even having me on because the
idea is gonna be well how could you have
on somebody election period or legit
amazing his point of view by having him
on I know a lot of people who I pull it
eclis disagree with who have had that
experience what will have me on their
show and it's like how dare you have
Shapiro on because you're just granting
him cover you know like or we can just
have a conversation and maybe we'll
disagree maybe we'll agree yeah I'd
really don't give a [ __ ] about those
people I think that's a silly
conversation III feel like you should
talk to everybody and if you disagree or
agree I have friends on that I my friend
yesterday I had on Eddie Bravo he
believes in everything's a [ __ ]
conspiracy I disagree with him wildly
and I love him like a brother I don't
think you have to agree with people and
I don't think you have to at the idea
that you can't just have a conversation
with someone about something and see if
he can find middle ground or see if you
could clearly define their point of view
or find their perspective that's missing
today in a weird way and one of the
weirdest things about the election was
the ping-pong match between the left and
the right has played out on national
television by the media I would watch
especially cable news I would watch fox
news and then go to CNN and go back and
forth lip channels you know you have
that previous channel but yeah on the
directv i would just put it on both of
them go what what world's my mom said
this in 2012 with Romney and Obama if
you read the right-wing media there was
no way Romney was gonna lose and if you
read the left-wing media there was no
way Romney was gonna win and she said
which one of these do I believe in it
sounds probably somewhere in the middle
like I have a basic rule which is that
if you have a New York Times report and
then you have a report from my site The
Daily wire and they share the facts you
can probably assume the facts are true
but the opinions that are you know
embedded with the facts those are
opinions right and that's what's so hard
about I think the modern media landscape
is trying to separate the facts from the
opinion and so this is why when Trump
says fake news he's not wrong that CNN
hates him and the New York Times hates
him that he's right about that but just
labeling it all fake news is inaccurate
also because most of what they're
reporting is true right it's just that
it's biased something can be both true
and biased
yeah I'm true and biased right I say
things that I think are factual but I'm
obviously conservative that's my point
of view you know touch it so that's and
you're a commentator right that's what
you do I mean half of it is you know
riling people up saying provocative
things I mean that's it's this is and
this is where I think the right is
correct about CNN in the New York Times
and some of the other networks like
though if that's the right what pisses
you off more CNN or the MSNBC most
people on the right will say CNN not
MSNBC because MSNBC is honest enough to
say we're on the left and CNN pretends
we have no bias we remove all that same
thing with the New York Times you know
we're above all that and then they run
the most egregiously biased headline so
we go well that if they're lying about
that they're lying about everything you
know one of my fast my most fascinating
characters if this whole play was Scott
Adams and particularly because Scott
Adams and when I had him on my podcast
he was saying he doesn't even vote yeah
he was like what I am what I am paying
attention to he goes I'm a trained
hypnotist and I'm paying attention to
the powers of persuasion and I'm looking
at trends and I'm making some
predictions that turned out to be
accurate and he's like he's looking at
trumpet he's not talking about trumping
these glowing terms he's talking about
him as being an effective persuader and
he lost millions of dollars because of
that opinion talking about a guy that
he's not even gonna vote for I mean this
is all leading up to the election where
people were [ __ ] furious at him yeah
and even more furious at him after Trump
won because he would do those coffe with
Scott things he does on periscope where
he wakes up but he's just starts asking
questions and he's so measured and calm
and I did he had a podcast recently with
Sam Harris where I think he was just
like a little too far over the edge of
apologizing for some of trumps behavior
and and sort of attributing some of
trumps behavior to that you could say
was incompetence and in tribute to the
like some some sort of a master but this
is my only quarrel with Scott I think is
that he tends to believe that everything
Trump does is 987 degree underwater
upside down Hungry Hungry Hippos like
everything is
it's all just apps of genius and it's
three steps down the road instead of
like stumbling his way to victory okay I
knew everyone involved in the campaign
like every single person who's involved
in the campaign I knew this was a
stumble their way to victory like it is
amazing the minds human beings are we
need to think it's sort of like the
Joker says in the Dark Knight we need to
think there's a plan we always need to
think there's a plan and so if Trump won
it must be because there was some master
plan that he unveiled over the course of
the campaign three weeks before the
election he was caught on tape saying
that he wanted to grab women by the
p-word no there was no master plan okay
it's just that Hillary was an awful
candidate and no one liked her okay the
idea that the Trump was like even the
idea that there was like broad national
movement for Trump that wasn't there for
other candidates he won fewer votes in
Wisconsin than Mitt Romney didn't he won
the state and that's because no one
liked Hillary I mean this is the untold
story of the elections this was not a
referendum on Donald Trump this was a
referendum on Hillary Clinton
particularly in the heartland and people
hated her guts right Barack Obama won
Ohio walking away everyone talks about
Michigan and Pennsylvania and in
Wisconsin nobody talks about Ohio Trump
won Ohio walking away one of the reasons
he want Ohio walking away is because in
2012 Barack Obama really drove out the
black vote the the percentage of the
black vote typically in Ohio it's like
10% of the general vote in 2012 is like
13 to 15 percent of the general vote and
that was the entire margin of victory
for Obama in the state of Ohio Hillary
got you know closer to sort of the
traditional percentages and she lost in
a whopping blowout in Ohio
no one likes Hillary Clinton in the left
was so arrogant that they thought we can
take the most unpopular unlikable
unqualified nasty boring human being
anyone has seen for 20 years and will
run her she's the one we'll run but do
you understand how incompetent you have
to loot it how incompetent you have to
be to lose to a celebrity game show host
like like you have to suck at this in a
royal manner
I don't know now now the thing the
floodgates are open but don't you think
senator big rock man yes oh he's gonna
win the primary if he didn't win the
primary and then he would have to run as
an independent then he'd be indie-rock
right
kid rock is gonna win the primary oh
well we can only hope once he's in the
office he grows into it he becomes adult
Rock how is Ted new do not run for
office yet that's what I want to know
how does he not you know him rock give
me a conversation about running for
president you know and that you know if
the people really wanted it he would do
it I was like oh good Jesus oh I just
can't wait for the rock Oprah you know
the rock might win The Rock might win on
it if Oprah ran in 2020 yeah she the
rock with Oprah
it's a [ __ ] dual slam-dunk of me yeah
the rock and Oprah together so I have
this weird idea that we should actually
reinstitute a monarchy and it should
just be ceremonial and they can be a
celebrity right I'll just make a
celebrity monarch okay and that person
will just be there to look pretty and so
what Queen of England
exactly but don't really have anything
no power no power because we keep
conflating the presidency with like who
actually has to do things right with
like people who want to represent the
country yeah we have unpopularity
contest see who gets to control the
nukes which is insane that's pretty wild
that's pretty wild I think that you know
this is we all think in in cinematic
terms now and you know Hollywood is run
by the the dopiest jackasses like I grew
up with all these people right these are
not people who you want controlling the
narrative and then we're like you know
what let's take if Tom Hanks would only
run if Tommy what makes you think Tom
Hanks would be a good president like did
you look at trumpeting what god he's
doing such a brilliant job but we really
need now is the guy from castaway we
need is an actor again we did well with
Regan
we need another actor we did great with
Schwarzenegger as the governor hey at
least Reagan was governor for 20 years
before he before he was the President of
the United States I mean let's let's put
him let's put him through the wringer I
mean Schwarzenegger proved in eight
years that he was not capable of doing
anything except kind of sucking well you
ever heard him talk about it the way it
from his perspective he's like you don't
really understand how much red tape and
[ __ ] you have to go through he goes
I would meet with people and they would
agree with me that it's a good idea
however they would say my voters are
never gonna agree with it so I'm gonna
oppose it even though I know you're
right there's a bunch of farmers that
are gonna be mad at me for doing that so
I'm not going to do that well this is
the other thing in politics that really
drives me not so there are two promises
that politicians make that are complete
[ __ ] the first promise they make is
I'm gonna go to Washington DC and I'm
gonna get things done no you're not okay
the system the system is built for
gridlock it's built for gridlock it's
where we have two separate houses of
Congress it's why we have a president
who can veto is why we have a Supreme
Court that rules on cases is built for
grid lights why we have States that are
supposed to be able to check the federal
government all this is in the Federalist
Papers it was built for gridlock and
some people are happy with that because
that's how Trump is being like sideline
that every time he tries to make
something really important I think we
all should be happy with that because
the only way things were supposed to get
past was with wide public support right
which is probably a good thing we don't
want the government shifting wildly and
veering on its axis every four years or
every two years
I like the gridlock my big problem is
that the gridlock now protects a huge
system that I don't like that's been
built up over a hundred years and in the
case of growth of government but I like
the gridlock but that's one promise
that's made and then people are
disappointed oh if we get in there we're
gonna repeal Obamacare it's like no
you're not you're not I mean like you
can promise it but now you're not gonna
do it because you're full of crap when
you said it and now you're not going to
do it and the gridlock is there and it's
hard to change things you know it takes
a tremendous effort of will and
electoral power to actually change
things in a big way so this idea will
let Trump and Trump like Trump would say
it's not gonna be so easy it's like no
it's not it's it wasn't easy for Obama
Obama passed Obamacare and that was it
for his presidency can do anything for
the next six years right there were no
major pieces of legislation nothing
happened after that he lost Congress and
that was it okay so that's promise
number one the other promise is your
anger is justified and this is one I
hate even more and that is the idea that
you know in in regular life when you
have kids I have kids when your kid is
angry the first thing you have to teach
your kid is maybe you're wrong to be
angry sometimes your anger is not
justified if you want to make good human
beings you have to determine whether
they are right to be angry is is your
anger correct politicians are in the
business of justifying people's anger oh
you hear this about the Trump voter a
lot right they're so angry they're so
angry
okay well I'm angry too about things but
are they angry about the right things
right and Trump would say you're right
to be angry because you've lost your job
in podunk Ohio because it's being stolen
by the Chinese or by the Mexicans or
something and it's like well is that
factually true or you just are just
pandering to the anger and on the left
you hear people say this to black folks
in the inner city it's the system that's
keeping it down it's a racist white
supremacist system that's keeping you
down then well is that true or I just
pandering to the voter because it's hard
to tell people hard truths why
you're not right to be angry get off
your ass and do something with your life
and this is true for regardless of race
you know go out there no one cares
enough to stop you and your life your
life is your own no one in the United
States cares about you wants to stop you
wants to throw obstacles up in your own
way I'm not sure you can win an election
on the basis of go live your own life
even though everyone keeps claiming they
want to live their own life I think most
people are full of it I think most
people don't want to live their own life
they want a politician to tell them
they're all of their complaints about
life being unfair are justified and the
politicians gonna solve all that we
don't want people who stay out of our
way we want people to be mommy men and
you know that's that's a tempting a
tempting proposition for politics
there's certain a lot of that when
you're talking to adults because you're
dealing with people that have the
momentum of all their failures in life
and all the different things that are
not going right and then here they are
at this moment today right now and they
want to figure out why and why they're
not on track and how to get on track and
the easiest way is to point the finger
or blame someone else and everybody has
their own hand I'm not saying that
people's hands are fair and that you
know it doesn't have it easy a lot of
people that have it easy I have it
easier than a lot of people for sure for
sure absolutely but the reality is
there's a tremendous amount of
psychological factors that go into why
someone does or does not succeed and to
placate them or to you know to play on
those psychological factors as you know
not being their own fault
it's very tempting because it works with
people people love to hear that they
love to hear that it's not your fault
yep and I think that's what politicians
have become in the business of doing and
it's both right and left it seems people
saying that it's it's not your fault
because you're being screwed by some
foreign country it's not your fault
because the immigrants are doing it to
you um it's not your fault maybe some
maybe some of that's true but you have
to show me why it's true you have to
show me what the actual like did you
lose your job because of and because of
China or did you lose your job because
you're in an industry that is being
crowded out because of technological
change and because your unions struck
and created wages too high to be
globally competitive like let's look at
the actual logic here is to and out and
then how can we change it how can we
make it better how can we is it
something we have to do or is it a
matter of you need to broaden your skill
set like you see a lot of people now who
are stuck in the mindset of 30 years ago
that you're gonna work
and stay there for twenty years and then
you're gonna grow and then you're gonna
you know leave with gold watch and
that's not the way the job market works
anymore I mean if you're if you're
entering the job market right now as a
college student you can expect that in
the next ten years you'll probably work
four jobs you know like the the turnover
is too great and you have to be
constantly increasing your skill set
also with every new innovation there's
businesses that branch out and become
new and then there's also businesses
that die and there's no bringing them
back you're not going to bring back the
printing press no there's a lot of stuff
that but for the guy in the printing
press industry you tell them that try to
get elected from the printing press guy
well I mean right now they're trying to
stop automatically wrote like within the
last day or two to try to block
automated trucks yeah yeah because
there's a tremendous amount of people
that yeah but it's gonna be a lot more
efficient when it's not people and you
know that this is the great fallacy
that's been people have been trying to
fight since the beginning of the
Industrial Revolution as this idea okay
well the new technology is gonna kill
jobs and then no one will ever work
again we've had the same unemployment
rate in this country for the last
hundred years and the technology is a
little bit better Teamsters convinced
Congress to block driverless trucks
that's yeah that's crazy crazy seems
crazy it seems like you're fighting an
inevitable tide well I mean imagine that
like how is that gonna work for all the
other industries that are affected let's
say that you now have you're
artificially raising the prices of all
the goods that now have to be brought in
by the Teamsters and now it's more
expensive so it's more money out of your
pocket in my pocket that's that's money
that I'm maybe I was willing to buy
American but now I'm gonna buy Chinese
cuz I have to feed my family like this
is that's not how economics works it's
just not how economics is there any
argument that they're not ready yet that
these that's one of the issues is that
with a lot of these so the automated
trucks basically in order for them to
work you need dedicated lanes because
otherwise human error is is something
that if like if there's a Google car on
the road and you're a bad driver the
Google car is probably gonna get in the
crash or maybe more likely getting a
crash than if we're human driving have
you ever seen people freak out those
Tesla cars and see what they could do to
them I haven't I haven't seen those
tests I actually saw somebody do two
Google car when you're when a car is on
that automated thing if you just swerve
they slam on the brakes and back up on
you like people have done it to people
and filmed it when I see people using
automated cars it's it's it's not done
it's not ready yeah it's the mix again
it's sort of like how there's a lot of
fuel-efficient lighter cars on the road
but they're a lot more dangerous than
the heavier cars because the heavier
cars the clunkers are still around from
1970 in their tanks yeah there's one
through three Priuses how do you feel
about universal basic income because
that's a subject that comes up a lot
lately when Elon Musk is talking about
these driverless cars one of the things
he's saying is that one thing that we're
going to need is universal basic income
he said we're going to have to figure
out some way to feed all these people
they're gonna get taken out of the job
market because their jobs are become
irrelevant so I think that universal
basic income is for when the technology
gets so good that they're legitimately
are no jobs I don't think that we're
there yet so if you have a machine that
can make everything basically for free
and then there's a bunch of people who
you don't need anymore to do work then
you can talk about a universal basic
income because there's no scarcity
scarcity is what creates a need for
labor so if there's scarcity in any
industry then there's going to be need
for labor there's gonna be need for new
labor people are gonna still have to you
know work on these trucks and deal with
technology and the computer industry
didn't destroy jobs all over the United
States when typewriters went out so I
think it's a little premature I'm not
sure there will ever be a day when
there's a machine that when the Machine
Society is so well developed that it can
take over all jobs I do think you're
seeing a bifurcation in the labor market
so I think people who are in jobs like
yours in mind like we're lucky this is a
creative job it's hard for machines to
create but for jobs that are single
tasks jobs a lot more of those are going
to be technologically driven and so
people are gonna have to you know work
the right side of their brain a little
bit and we're gonna have to train people
in a different way but my perspective on
universal basic income is when you have
a four percent unemployment rate it's
very difficult to say you need a
universal basic income like it's again
96 percent of people in the labor market
who can work are working so that's not
that's not that's not suggesting to me
that there's this vast underclass of
people who are totally incapable of
working and once you do that you see
what you've seen actually with the
disability programs in the United States
right we're now everybody's on
disability like the fastest growing
government program in America is the
disability program where people declare
themselves disabled so that they can get
government
pensions basically once you have
universal basic income is there an
incentive to work and also I'm not sure
that you've solved a lot of people's
problems like people still see need
something to do with their day yeah 16
year-olds do you see who retired and
they're dead within three years the
utopian idea is that somehow they going
to open up these people's inherent
creativity and they'll find something
Joey I mean how many people say
thirty-three using the term hooey yeah I
love it
it's a again you know I'm never I hope
I'd never retire because I just know too
many people who are retire and their oh
I'm gonna retire and I'm in a Gulf
another paint I'm free and six months
later they're dead yeah well people
enjoy doing things and feeling like
they're valuable you know and I don't
know if that necessarily has to be a job
but it's a very clear definitive test of
whether or not you're valuable if
somebody gives you money and you get
that money you're like look I'm valuable
I'm doing something I'm contributing I
got a check for my week exactly there's
there's a lot of hours in the day and
it's gonna be hard to fill that with
watercolor painting and beat poetry
classes ah I don't know man I'd find
[ __ ] to do but I see but I I've been
fairly self employed most of my life
yeah I think I just I've gotten and some
people are driven like I would find
stuff to do too but it's there is a
difference and you know not all human
beings are the people who would actually
go out and take classes and find things
to do do you have aspirations outside of
commentary when it comes to politics
maybe some point down the road do you
think you run for president or something
like that I mean apparently anyone can
and this is what I'm finding is sure so
um but you're a reasonable guy uh I
don't know I mean I I like what I'm
doing in the sense that I get to work on
what people believe which i think is
sort of the root of politics I'm not
sure implementing is the same thing as I
said I'm not sure that the president can
get like I'm more focused on getting
people to think in the terms that I'd
like them to think you know about
limited government and you taking
control of your own life and I might be
able to do more good you know
promulgating that message using a
growing medium like we're very lucky I
mean or the podcast went from having
three thousand listeners you know three
hundred episodes ago to now we have
three hundred thousand listeners a day
you know so it's it's it continues to
grow so
as that crowd continues to grow it's
actually harder for me to said I'd want
to jump into politics not easier I think
the limited government thing to me has
always been a fascinating subject
because the people that don't want
limited government they're always that
is the utopian ideal in my mind yeah
somehow or another the government's
gonna be effective if you give them more
money like well this is an argument with
a friend where he wanted people to be
taxed more because he felt like that
money could be distributed to people and
you would get like more funding for the
Arts was one of his arguments but my
thought was like first of all the arts
like when their value when people like
them they pay for him yep that's not get
it and funding for the Arts means you're
gonna have like [ __ ] LACMA I'll show
the LA County Museum the art [ __ ] box
on the ground that someone's calling a
piece of art that guy whether you went
to it was either in San Francisco or at
LACMA
where he went there and he took off his
glasses and he just put them on the
floor and then he stood next to them
going you know kind of standing there
and kind of stroking his chin seen there
were 30 people all around him staring
the glasses on the floor it's like it's
amazing yeah it's [ __ ] horseshit
right that the modern art exhibits like
there's there was another one recently
with someone like left behind a
pineapple yeah I remember this yeah yeah
it's just it's crazy it really is crazy
and it's all so pretentious and it's
also stoking those fires of pretension
and making something that's not
legitimately creative making it
celebrated because you don't really have
the ability to create something that's
legitimately creative yeah yeah I was
pointing this out today with regard to
it's funny how a lot of people who want
bigger government they embrace states
that start to grow the government and
then when things go to [ __ ] they're like
nowhere to be found
so Venezuela is the most obvious example
right Venezuela has turned from what was
the richest country in South America and
had the best oil reserves of anywhere in
the Western Hemisphere basically they've
turned it into just a garbage heap
people waiting in lines have a friend
named Nami Horowitz who went down there
did some documentary stuff down there
and he was I think his cameraman got
shot he was who's watching people like
literally shooting dogs in the streets
for food and this is I mean it's Caracas
is the most violent city in the Western
Hemisphere now and all of this is
because Hugo Chavez was a piece of
garbage
who centralized all power to himself
redistributed the wealth to all of his
friends and cronies and then and then
supposedly up
did the poor accept that now everyone is
poor Wayne Ranney wasn't he friends with
Sean Penn I don't even know what you're
saying
exactly so so I'm my show today I played
like Sean Penn and Jesse Jackson and and
that Freak Jeremy Corbyn who's the head
of the Labour Party in Great Britain and
they're all just praising Chavez right
he's the great guy he was a hero to the
poor and now Venezuela's going to [ __ ]
and we're all these people like what
would someone stick a camera in Sean
Penn split face like now and just ask
Sean Penn so like five minutes ago you
were saying this was awesome but there's
got to be some sort of a left response
for that like what what is their take on
the no true Scotsman fallacy right
though well you know this is them living
on it's because they never really got
rid of enough private industry if they'd
just gone further it would have been
better it's like low Soviet Union and
didn't work out that great either but
like I got actually got a response it
was really funny today I tweeted out
that according to the World Bank
Venezuela has one of the least income
unequal societies on earth so it's
actually pretty income equal reckons
nobody has anything right and then it's
garbage and so the the Socialists the
official Socialist Party tweeted me and
they said this is because socialism has
never truly been tried okay all right
sure
[Music]
well the wonderful idea of socialism is
that it's going to even everything out
and that you shouldn't get paid more for
that no one should get paid more and
then everyone should have some sort of a
like a peak that you could reach right
and think there's some sort of
competition involved there's got to be
some there's got to be some sort of
incentive but only so much right this is
like the Bernie said this is democratic
socialism like formal socialism is the
state owns the whole thing but
democratic socialism is there's private
industry but only to a certain point and
then we tell people no no then you find
out about Bernie and his wife and his
wife's idea was to buy up a bunch a land
and expand the college and then the
[ __ ] college went under and now
they're being sued vacation homes yeah
come on man it's all based on a lot of
myth making about like Western Europe
and and the Netherlands right so there's
always two outs democratic socialist
countries they're working great first of
all a car in Denmark has a 60% import
tax and costs literally twice what it
would cost in the United States tax
rates in Denmark are insane except for
corporate taxes which the left in the
United States
really you know they love corporate
action they want those higher Denmark
has some of the lowest corporate taxes
and regulations in the industrialized
world so everybody is coming in and
investing in Denmark it's only the
citizens who are getting screwed by
paying for this giant welfare state then
their GDP tanked and now they've had to
elect right-wing governments to slash
back the the level of government I mean
it turns out that capitalism is the
great engine that dry like Singapore is
there's nothing on Singapore right
Singapore is like a rock ok City there's
nothing there Singapore has one of most
powerful economies on earth because they
basically have no business regulations
no taxes and no tariffs so you need
whatever you want and when people can do
whatever they want they make a lot of
mutually beneficial exchanges end of
story this is not that difficult but but
it is difficult if you think that life
is unfair right so what would you
propose like what would you propose for
the United States like the United States
obviously what Trump wants to do is
reinvigorate manufacturing make things
in America again bring back the labor
force make take away the jobs that are
going to overseas and other countries in
South America so I think that that's a
bunch of slogans from him and I don't
think it means in it so so number one I
don't think a manufacturing job is more
important than a tech job right ok a job
is a job and in industries that are
thriving you actually need more jobs and
in industries that are not doing as well
if the jobs disappear that's just the
wages of a global economy and that's I
know that sounds harsh to people who are
in those industries but it's not a
referendum on you or your value it's
just saying that certain industries over
time always you know are outsourced like
we used to make t-shirts in the United
States we don't make t-shirts here make
them in Vietnam and it cost us like five
bucks right so the so my view is I'm not
gonna privilege ones I understand a lot
of this is politics you want a favored
manufacturing bases because there are a
lot of manufacturing hubs in
Pennsylvania Ohio Michigan Wisconsin but
then they vote since I don't care right
since I'm not a politician my view is
that if you want a thriving economy you
relieve as much regulation as possible
you lower the taxes for everyone
personal and corporate you attract as
much foreign investment as possible and
you allow people to build businesses
with this little risk as possible and
then you allow them to compete and if
they succeed they succeed and if they
fail they fail and you get rid of
tariffs as well because I want cheap
inputs for my products and I want cheap
products on the shelves at the store so
don't have to pay a bajillion dollars
for a pair of shoes so I'm my view of
this is that economics is an element of
freedom I am a free person I get to do
with my money what I damn well
and you don't get to stand in my way
unless there is some sort of moral thing
right like if you want to say let's put
sanctions on let's put sanctions on Iran
let's put sanctions on China right
China's funding North Korea right now it
hurts our national security we want to
put sanctions on China to try and
pressure them into ending North Korea
that's a national security thing but the
idea that like today Trump rolled out
this new plan on immigration and he says
I want to cut down on legal immigration
but the reason is because I want to
raise wages of people in the United
States and I think well that's not
productive because what you're actually
doing is you're restricting the supply
of labor artificially increasing the
wages which artificially increases
prices which means it's not competitive
on a global scale which means the
company's outsourced right so it's the
exact same thing as minimum wage you
create a minimum wage you're
artificially increasing wages that
increases prices that makes it
non-competitive people outsource so it
actually achieves the opposite of what
you're trying to achieve all government
intervention in the economy save for
interventions that are designed to
prevent externalities now things that I
do that hurt you
all of those are unjustified in my view
what about an environmental protection
so those are externalities right so like
if I were to pollute a river it's not my
River I don't get to pollute it right I
get to throw my trash over my fence into
your yard right that's a that's that's a
different thing that's it yeah that's
one of the most disturbing things about
this administration is the cutting the
funding for the Environmental Protection
Agency and the changing of their
standards removing some of the funding
for things like satellites that they're
using to track the climate change and
things along those lines and that that
scares the [ __ ] out of me
like it scares the [ __ ] out of means
they're gonna ignore the environment in
favor of the economy so I think that
some of the environmental regulations
are badly drawn and some of them are
overwrought when it comes to for example
fracking you know Obama pushed a lot of
environmental regulations on fracking or
the Keystone XL pipeline that kind of
thing how do you feel about fracking I'm
very much in favor of fracking what do
you think about like when you hear
stories about more earthquakes happening
and in stable water supplies from what
I've seen the the earthquake evidence is
extraordinarily weak yeah the myth from
what I've seen you know I'm again if you
present me evidence that I find
convincing I'm happy to change my mind
on this right
and as far as the as far as water
pollution again the evidence has been
pretty weak so if that changes then I'm
happy to regulate it as far as when you
say that's been weak there's there has
been instances of fracking leading to
pollution right sure but that's not
every fracking leads to pollution right
and so the question is is the regulation
or how many are you willing to accept
right which is the truth for all
business right like how much we all
drive cars how much pollution air water
bottles somewhere there's a seagull
choking on a cab correct so like how
much are you willing to accept like what
I don't appreciate is when people kind
of futz the evidence or it's like oh
well I accept my set my water on fire
because of fracking it's like no that's
not because of fracking that's because
of the groundwater but in any case the
you know as far as the satellites and
global warming listen I think that it's
pretty clear that the climate is warming
I mean the greenhouse gas effect is a
thing the question to me is less whether
it's happening and more what are you
going to do about it because even the
left seems to have no real solutions as
to what to do except for massively
cutting economic growth and it seems to
me that if we're talking about an
increase according the IPCC if something
like 7 degrees Fahrenheit over the
course of the next century then on
average right not not universally on
average then it seems to me that it's
easier to just say that the climate
changes over time and maybe cities that
are on the coast are gonna have to pull
back a little bit over time like a
hundred years a long time a hundred
years ago we would have said that the
the pollution was the chief thing to
worry about in the United States cuz
we're all using smokestacks and it's
exactly and and now not really even
through regulation but just through
market competition you've gotten better
environmental products so I think that
the market does take care of a lot of
these things people don't actually want
to live in in human waste you know like
we actually don't want to do that I know
what's been disturbing me recently is
how many times I see Bill Nye on TV
talking about climate change
well he's it again he's he has the same
qualifications I do I mean he's like a
mechanical engineering degree yeah kind
of a comedian yeah I mean I think he is
my childhood yes I believe he was like a
comedian he's a stand-up guy yeah yeah
and he does you ever see is this thing
with Tucker Carl
which was great
Tucker Carlson kept saying okay but
you're talking about science so tell me
how much of an effect do human beings
have on climate change and what what is
what's the science
Chimay and all he wanted to say was that
you know are you a consensus settle yeah
exactly and like what is what is the
difference or it's changing right give
me a range like you don't even have to
be an exact number but give me a range
and then tell me okay what do we have to
do in order in your opinion in order to
stop the climate change right where it
stands or if we can't do that in order
to minimize it what's the actual risk
also and people keep giving these
catastrophic scenarios where it looks
like the day after tomorrow and Dennis
Quaid running into subways and [ __ ]
weirder ones he said was that we were
supposed to have an ice age now that's
not gonna happen like Jesus Christ man
that's good yeah you know Randall
Carlson has been on my podcast a few
times and he's an expert in collisions
and asteroid collisions and one of the
things he said is like he goes global
warming is not great he goes but it's
way better than global cooling this is
true cooling kills ever there right
though the Little Ice Age was not a good
thing for the world I mean the global
warm period was actually a pretty good
thing for the world so I mean this is
this is the other thing is that there
are costs and benefits to the climate
changing which would hit which it has
throughout time right what are we
willing to sacrifice in order to prevent
in order to make that seven degrees into
six degrees right and just losing some
coastline is not the real issue
intervention is far more devastating
right I mean losing coasts so I think
that if you're gonna worry about that if
you're gonna worry about you know the
emissions problem worry about the the
the sea absorption of emissions right
now like the toxification of the oceans
like that seems to me to be a bigger
problem than the climate changing over
time we're pretty adaptable like there's
a lot of land okay so we move we have
historically right I mean Venice the the
sea-level rise in Venice every year
people are going to move I mean like
that's just that's the way it works I am
absolutely there's this weird idea and
it's it's true in economics it's true
with global warming that where you were
born is where you must die hmm
right and then you can never move and
it's like well this is the most mobile
society in human history we were on a
plane and be on the other coast in six
hours it's it's easier to move than ever
before so if we if you really think that
the climate is that bad first of all I'd
like to ask Barbara Streisand if she's
that deeply concerned about global
warming why she doesn't sound a
coastline of state yeah but is it's
like am I gonna lose a lot of sleep of a
bunch of Hollywood stars lose you know
five feet off their coastline because we
didn't kill the industry of the United
States and lose four trillion dollars a
year like me no and I'm not really sure
that that would have worked that way one
way or another the it has been
absolutely proven that human beings are
having an effect on this carbon dioxide
levels of course of course yeah there's
a greenhouse gas effect sure a hundred
percent so modeling's been so wrong that
like I want there's no level of
certitude and then there's no level of
solution that I know for sure is going
to do this so you're talking about human
being suffering in the now for the later
and let's be real about this like yes
there are a lot of emissions from the
United States but the leading emitter is
on the planet right now we're trying in
India and they're not gonna stop this
Russian anytime soon like that's not
gonna happen well there's also this
thing that happens where if you even
discuss it you become like a Hitler or a
Nazi you become a climate change denier
and once you get locked into one of
those labels you know you you're a piece
of [ __ ] well this is and yeah nobody
wants to be locked into those labels so
they don't want to have the discussion
of the debate and that's one of the
things that I felt like Bill Nye was not
prepared for because I felt like he's so
lazy with this conversation because so
many people just appease him and agree
with it yeah I think that's when Tucker
Carlson was challenging him on it he
didn't have any data to support this
argument he just wanted to sort of like
play word games and and have this we you
know say well you know you guys on CNN
there was one time when when they had
some guy on who was saying exactly what
we were saying that the models did they
have not been proven to be accurate and
that Al Gore's movie predicted that we'd
be underwater in 2014 he didn't it yeah
I mean his predictions in that movie or
not correct yeah they're not correct at
all whoo and he's made like some insane
amount of money he's gonna sequel out
this week isn't he like the first
billion dollar green guy yeah like he's
made a shitload of money off of giving
these speeches and cap-and-trade and the
whole thing is very strange because it
becomes this untouchable subject like
what we're talking about before with
transgender people or with many other
subjects become you can't discuss them
they're not even open to debate or Chris
they they become locked down and when
tucker carlson was pressing bill not
like what is what are the numbers like
what is happening tell me how much of an
effect are we having and Bill Nye had
nothing on it and became stammered and
started getting angry is like wow this
is weird
yeah this is weird to see I mean if this
is the cause of your life you should
know a little bit more about it then
everyone who disagrees is a denier and I
think the way Tucker handled it was
brilliant Tucker's best moment I think
on a show yeah I think so too because he
was saying essentially he was like I'm
not denying it I'm not saying aside I
just want you to tell me but the effect
tell me he'll be hanged and he had
nothing it's like so maybe Bill Nyes the
wrong guy to have their I shouldn't be
selling himself like you can't have me
come on a [ __ ] show and talk about
plot global warming because I don't know
anything right or at the very least
Bill Nye should say listen the you know
Intergovernmental Panel on Climate
Change did this study right you can look
up the numbers there I don't have them
off the top of my head or the numbers
right how about [ __ ] numbers you're
gonna be on one of those shows seven
minutes so everybody in the media is
lazy nobody nobody actually does their
prep for debate or for TV appearances
like because the truth is you think
you're gonna be on for fight having done
a thousand TV heads at this point most
people think ok I'm beyond for five
minutes I can get through five minutes
right I'm gonna be that bad if I'm on
for 10 minutes how bad can it be
and the answer is you can get pantsed on
national TV in five minutes if the
person knows what they're doing well
you've done that too many people one of
the things that I think is do you talk
fast always you're born this way
everyone my family talks the family just
talks from me as I was wondered if this
like was a strategy developed to be
really good at those shows no no it's
it's it's been fortunate that it that it
fits that way but yeah even even my kids
don't talk this way even the
three-year-old to see some people that
are just really good at Baba Baba and
you you get them in the podcast and
after like Peter shifts a great example
after like 20 minutes I'm like you want
a drink let's have some whiskey I had a
couple of glasses of Clank
cheers and we settled down and then he
settled into like a normal way of
talking but he's just so used to like
force feeding you fats and pans and it's
just it's such an ineffective way to
communicate with those three heads and
the the one person who is the host throw
the megyn kelly throwing a question
this person's talking over that person
and it's such an ineffective way to
communicate yeah I mean it's one of the
things that I do like about you know
long-form podcast like this one or like
mine I just I like the ability to
actually expand on a point yeah on TV
it's like okay you have 30 seconds of a
point excellent we can make that work
for us
it's the only place left that you can do
this unless you're making youtube videos
and you know Jordan Peterson is
obviously finding out that that's
problem yeah but unless you're unless
you're doing something along those lines
where no one's there but you and you get
to expand and express yourself there's
no other form of conversation like
podcasts where you're not getting
interrupted by a commercial you're just
talking and you know as well as I know
that conversations sort of evolve and
move and they you know when I get to
know you better I see how you're
thinking better and I kind of have more
questions to ask and you expand more and
you get to know a person for real and
that's just those those television shows
are so there it's so divisive and
honestly it's hard for me to watch a
cable television because of that I don't
feel like I'm making tons of information
that way well CNN had nine [ __ ]
people on the other day that's crazy the
panel on CNN it's like it's Hollywood
Squares no Anderson Cooper standing
sitting there in the middle and there's
people and then there's people that I do
I made a diagonal cool and they're
interrupting each other and said excuse
me while I talk you mind not
interrupting me for a moment like
they're they're grandstanding and trying
to have this this point they think is
gonna be a zinger because they wrote it
last night and it's just like oh the
best you can hope for is that you have
30 seconds where you say something that
goes viral that's basically this that's
the extent of it yeah well you've done a
lot of those yeah but it's like we were
talking about before that a lot of the
people that have debated you that are
really they're really [ __ ] lazy like
like they have this supposed passion for
something but when it comes to preparing
for this sort of interaction they're not
really doing that they're not for sure
and I think that you know part of that
is there are people who are experts on
particular topics who could I'm sure
know more about their specialty than I
do on a lot of topics like if I were
discussed climate change with a person
who was like an expert on climate change
I would not know as much as that person
sure but you know there are a lot of
people who think they're generalists and
have never read a book right you know
I know one fact about one thing and it's
that you're a denier you know and I well
I mean if I know two then I beat you
well that's that so the climate denier
thing seems to me one of the laziest
things about the left and this is not
saying that there's not some sort of a
real issue with human waste because I
think there is I think it's a jet
there's a giant issue with plastic in
the ocean
there's a giant issue with pollutants in
our water system in our air and there's
a lot of issues with the side effects of
being a person in an industrialized
civilization there's we burn things we
create poisons and we've got to figure
out a way to be sustainable I don't
think there's any denying that by
anybody I think it's also worth noting
the market makes these things better in
many cases I mean the fact is that if
you look at the the areas where for
example everyone is down on carbon-based
fuels okay fair enough
but if you go to places that don't have
carbon-based fuels they're burning
animal dung and wood there's nothing
worse for a particulate than animal dung
and wood so as we get banned if we if we
did even better than than this we would
get to nuclear power right which
unfortunately a lot of people have
banned because of on base fears like
most of France's electricity is provided
by nuclear power and that's about as
clean as it gets so you know I do think
this how it goes dark
well till it goes to Fukushima a even
even in worst case scenario at Fukushima
I mean if you're talking about the if
you're talking about global warming and
environmental damage the amount of
environmental damage supposedly done by
carbon emissions is a lot larger than
Fukushima right but the local damage oh
yeah it's devastating
that's the disturbing thing that they
don't have a way to stop that that like
they've figured out a way to like put a
wall of ice around the containment area
and that didn't work it seems so [ __ ]
science fictiony they'd really don't
know what to do and yeah I don't know
enough about nuclear containment to take
off on that one better tomorrow let's
just say that one disaster in and
basically there been three major
disaster right renoble Three Mile Island
in Fukushima yeah the only one that's
happened two of those three have
happened in the first world right
Fukushima and Three Mile Island Three
Mile Island basically ended up having no
long-term impact so Fukushima is really
the only major disaster in 40 years of
industrialized countries using nuclear
power well apparently they had some
weird meltdowns here at Rocketdyne
weren't really discussed
yeah tell about it well they're there
you know it's it was all during the 60s
50s or the 60s when they're involved in
the rocket program but the Rocketdyne
stuff my friend's dad is a scientist
who's explaining to me the half-life of
whatever was released in the atmosphere
it's nothing in concern but there's a
bunch of rocket times like return Street
there was a bunch of articles that were
written about it like worrying about
people that have higher cancer rates in
this area and you know but there's also
like I think there's a website called
the sins of Rocketdyne really yeah see
if you can find that I think there's a
website dedicated to that that people
but there's a lot of cancer just living
in cities man like they say that one of
the worst environments for human beings
living in a place that has a lot of
brake dust like if you're living in
Manhattan and you get your window open
you're just inhaling particulates from
people there it is the sins of rocket
time but the thing is like I mean how
much more cancer are these people this
is from 2000s sometimes the statistics
on cancer are hard to correlate right is
it because you'll have groupings that
are sort of weird and that's just
because random statistical grouping yeah
so how much of it is due to X Factor or
Y factor if we do that then presumably
the cancer race would be going down a
lot you know they haven't really in most
cases so it's pretty rare you have like
a lung cancer situation where smoking
obviously causes lung cancer most
cancers like breast cancer we have no
idea why it happens also the valley
itself anything that happens in the
valley like you when you drive from like
Thousand Oaks over the hill and you look
down the valley and like Jesus that
can't be good yeah I hear you I've been
flying into the valley my entire life
and every time you fly into the brown
gunk soup that is that is the valley
atmosphere you think that's not great
yeah you mean that is one area where
obviously we have gotten better I mean
the smog alerts have gone down
tremendously in the last 30 years yeah
it's gotten a lot better it's gotten a
lot better and but that's also one of
the things that Donald Trump has relaxed
some of the standards the kind of
standards wasn't I don't know the
mission standards he changed the car
emission standards maybe it's again I
wonder how much of the car emission
standards like there's there's actually
thriving debate and libertarian
community particularly about whether
cave standards are what drove greater
fuel efficiency or whether it was the
price of gas that drove greater fuel
efficiency that as the price of gas has
has risen and fallen you see people
change their buying habits right in the
90s everybody but an SUV right and then
the prices went up and everybody bought
a Prius
well the Prius thing is interesting too
it particularly the Tesla thing because
then you look at the environmental
disasters of creating these batteries
yes and you're like oh this is not
totally green yeah like there's some
weird gray area too it's pretty complex
and and I think that the one thing we
know is that there are millions of
people all over the world for all of
human history who have been living in
absolute penury and misery and we now
support 7 billion people on the planet
and the rate of global poverty has
dropped by 50% in the last 30 years a
lot of that is technological change a
lot of that is fossil fuel use and so
before we you know we always have to ban
these are two things that are worth
thinking about balancing like and this
is what's again a little frustrating is
that sometimes you see people on the
environmental left will say well this
has to be done or it's the end of the
world and so well how about those people
in developing countries how many of
those people you're gonna say have to
live in poverty in order for this to
happen right and then on the right
you'll see people say well no
environmental regulations at all just
let it all hang out and you know
sometimes the market hashes it out and
sometimes the market doesn't hash it out
and so you know I think a little caution
is warranted I think that's a very
reasonable point of view and that's one
of the things that I really like about
your commentary I know you're a
right-leaning guy but you're very
reasonable you you make arguments that
are sound and easy to trace it makes
sense well thank you I appreciate it I
think we need more of that you know and
I think that's it's rare that you find
that in a 33 year old guy that's some
strange sort of conservative character
that travels around clowns so the
Berkeley thing is gonna happen when is
it gonna happen as September 14th is the
date it's supposed to happen dude good
luck with all that yeah well you know if
they cancel will still del you're gonna
go on a bulletproof popemobile yeah hey
where's bunny Han so do I do yours this
a low profile though yeah we keep it on
the DL around here let you when you when
you do show up at these places and you
see the anti-fur people and they're
screaming and yelling
cheering and that's got to be a surreal
thing that it's just you and your
thoughts and your opinion I mean you're
not selling babies you're not there
slaughtering dogs and this win festival
exactly it's weird I think that you know
I'm not I'm not arrogant quite enough to
think that a lot of those people know
who I am I think that what happens is
that they're sort of a call that goes
out from a select few saying this KKK
members coming to campus go would go
stop him that's what happened to Cal
State LA like when I spoke there there
were actually a couple professors were
telling their students that I was a
closeted member of the KKK you might
show up wearing a yarmulke I'm their
favorite person I think okay I'm like a
charter member
it's my thing I was literally in his
larry's that year I was kid 2016 is a
wild year so I was so David Duke accused
me of being a far leftist black lives
matter accused me of being a member of
the KKK and I was the number one
recipient of anti-semitism from the
according to the anti-defamation league
I was the number one recipient of
Twitter anti-semitism in the United
States for journalists last year's
little trophy at my house green frog it
is it's a green frog and then a little
model of the gas chambers murder number
one yeah by a huge margin by the way
hello out it was like 40% of all
anti-semitic tweets on the Internet
directed a journalist in 2016 were
directed to me personally holy [ __ ] it
was a good year has a good year you know
some years are more productive than
others what did that feel like well I
mean it felt like my Twitter feed was
just out a dumpster fire did anybody I
get somebody get people emailing me
please don't retreat me because I really
thought they'd just be hit by waves of
these people that's died off yes since
the election it's really gone down a
fair bit but you know there were some
pretty serious you know death threats
like I got people calling my cell phone
up my security I had it I already had a
shotgun but yeah well what what started
at all probably me quitting Breitbart
so so when I was you know I was not I
was not a trump supporter I didn't vote
for either candidate in this year's
watching or support in the primaries
Chris yeah Cruz I support him his
positions he was the closest to me
politically um so you know I was not pro
Trump during the primaries he didn't
earn my vote during the general
action I thought like there's two ways
to look at your vote and this is what I
always said to people I said vote for
who you want to but for me there's two
ways to look at your vote it's a coupon
that expires November 9th right and so
either user you lose it or it's just it
says something about what you are
willing to accept and it's possible that
there can be election where both
candidates suck and you just don't want
either of them so what did you do during
the election I voted down ticket I
skipped the top of the ticket so which
it first time I've ever done that so I
didn't think either of these people was
qualified to be President of the United
States once Trump was elected then it
was like okay if he does good stuff I'll
praise him if he does bad stuff well
I'll hit him as I would any other
presidents mhm so I've been sort of you
know calling balls and strikes with him
and some of the stuff like Gorsuch I
love and some of the stuff like Mika
Brzezinski bloody face I'm not so hot on
so it's but yeah so the I think what led
off was it was a combination of three
things one I'm Jewish too and obviously
so too I was working up right Bart and
then I quit in the middle of the
election cycle after there was that
whole remember the Michelle fields
incident where a Corey Lewandowski grabs
a reporter from ripe are they gone after
bruiser and then right did he actually
bruiser a bruiser I mean like she took
picture she reported to the cops it was
you know unless unless you believe she
bruised herself
it didn't look much like a I mean when I
watch the videos like it looked like he
just kind of grabbed her arm it looked
like he her body didn't like move like
she was being injured yeah I mean she
let's put it this way she that was her
account I was also the accounts of Ben
Terrace at the Washington Post right was
that she was grabbed hard enough to
bruise and then she had bruises you know
what let me as a fight commentator
there's a lot of things that I see live
that look a lot worse than when you
watch them on video
mm-hm you know when people get knocked
out like that wasn't much of a punch
like oh you had to be there yeah I mean
the most the example that comes to mind
is the alley Liston punch right number
two yeah might of mine is that that she
there were three there are a bunch of
different excuses that Breitbart won
through on that one one was that she was
never grabbed at all the second was it
was a Secret Service guy and then the
third was that that from thought she was
a security threat and Corey Lewandowski
had to protect Trump from this 90 pounds
soaking wet you know girl and so once
Breitbart did that then the real
question for me was not you know what a
horrible thing had happened to her it
was much more about as a journalistic
entity do you stand by Europe
or do you stand by the candidate who you
support and once Breitbart made clear to
me that it like I already knew they
supported Trump that was in a great
shock but I was kind of their token
non-trump guy and once it became clear
that they were willing to sort of
sacrifice journalistic credibility on
the altar of getting close to Trump then
I was out then it's no longer
journalistic outlets I quit and and that
sort of started the ball rolling so I
really didn't get anti-semitic responses
on Twitter before that and not too much
not too much so I won't see the
Breitbart directed dynamics I don't
think they did but I think that there
are a lot of people who follow Breitbart
and you know my low-key innopolis and
they're pissed at me and they'd see me
as like an ally and now they saw me as
an enemy and this kind of thing so and
you know it's a war for them right oh
yeah I mean people enjoyed it obviously
that's a weird thing about the online
hate is how much people enjoy it
what's anonymous you never get me never
get tagged for it for now it's not us
for now for now I mean I've said this to
a bunch of college students about you
know the alt-right the first of all I
think it's important didn't mention a
lot of people who say they're alright
aren't actually alright just cuz you
like a meme doesn't make you alright but
like there's a group of people who
actually like Richard Spencer and Jared
Taylor and the race-based identity
politics of white supremacy and those
people are actually alright when the
alt-right is is coming after you then
it's not a lot of fun but there there
are a lot of there are a lot of young
students who will retweet things from
like things that are obviously nasty and
gonna hurt them in their future career
yeah right where they'll build like be
joking around on Facebook and using the
n-word and I'll say to them like guys
you may think it's funny and ten years
from now your employer's gonna find that
and you're gonna be toast and there are
a lot of people who sort of fall into
this idea that what you do online is
anonymous and it is not it is not going
to remain enough it's just a matter of
time for it blows yeah I mean any
anonymity in ten years I agree I think
that we're moving in that direction and
this is actually a thing that bothers me
in general like did you follow the entry
to the Donald sterling saga
yeah sure so it really bothered me yeah
I mean did everybody was willing to like
take Donald Sterling's team away from
him because he said something shitty to
his girlfriend right about Magic Johnson
when there's no evidence that there's
actual discrimination among clients at
the Clippers only right
again if there are actual evidence of
discrimination then sure boycott his
team and do what the MBA has to do but
like I'm pretty certain that every human
being says crappy things to their
intimate loved ones about groups of
people and other people it was the
standard then I think that we're all
toast oh for sure in his defense of it
was like very reasonable she's trying to
get laid
he's like I was just I was just saying
it was like he thought he was alone he
thought he was with her and no one was
recording him and she was trying to say
that she had recorded all of their
conversations that it was a part of her
job he's like a senile old guy and he's
obviously not with Vee stiviano because
she's a Nobel Prize winning physicist I
mean like this is it like he bought her
a condo and a Bentley and a Ferrari and
she's a [ __ ] his interview his
interview with Anderson Cooper was one
of the classic interviews of all time I
ever saw oh my goodness that the moment
where he says because there's a moment
where he turns to Anderson Cooper says
Anderson have you ever fallen in love
with a woman in Anderson Cooper who is
you know super gay yeah everything goes
he starts laughing goes no I've never
had that experience well I understand
when you do fall in love with a woman
and he just get he's so unaware it it's
like I'm sorry like I can't consider
this guy like he's a KKK threatening
figure like the guy can't even like find
the toilet in the mornings he's like
stumbling over his ottoman like I had I
did about him defending him I was like
because if you look at what he actually
said everyone's like he's a race is a
terrible person
he said do me if it was I don't he goes
don't take pictures of black guys he
goes in the next sentence he said I
don't care if you [ __ ] them just don't
take pictures of them I go in my world
that's pretty reasonable like you gotta
go you can [ __ ] him she should just like
leave well enough alone you're getting a
Ferrari out of the deal no I think that
was that whole thing was just like it
was it was our capacity to get ourselves
to outraged so we could show everybody
how outraged we work well the president
of the NBA whatever the [ __ ] his name is
what is Adam silver the guy that got on
TV was talking about Italy was the most
horrific thing that's ever been said to
Jim Crow at
clipper at the Staples Center he should
have gotten on TV and said look this is
obviously we know what this was this is
a gold digger and an old man it's a
story as old as time he said some stupid
[ __ ] old people
say stupid [ __ ] he's an old guy here's
the thing don't take his advice when it
comes to race and and he probably should
have said look but on the bright side he
told that she can go [ __ ] black guy so
hey everybody's like self-righteous
[ __ ] and well I mean oh a lot of
that again is I think that if you look
at the NBA statistics and who watches
the NBA the the out sighs number of
people who watch the NBA are black and
this has amount of time watching it and
so you know Donald sterling pissed off a
lot of black folks with that
understandably and so a lot of people
were like I think the NBA is like we're
not gonna lose our fan base over there
was a money decision in other words I
don't think it was a values decision as
much as money well I agree with you 100%
but I don't think they had to make that
decision that way I think they could
they could have divested him and put him
like put his kids or his wife in charge
of the team like this idea that you're
gonna force him to sell his team it's
crazy disband the Clippers because there
was a tape of an old man saying stupid
ass things to a gold-digger is its to
anyway and he wound up making more money
from that team that he ever would have
so much jillion dollars yeah it became
much more valuable the whole thing is
bizarre yeah um that's it dude we just
hit three hours well that's crazy
I appreciate clue bye that's great well
listen people been asking for a long
time for you to come on so I'm glad we
finally got together and yeah me do it
thanks for having me my pleasure let's
do it again sounds good thank you thanks
Ben see you guys see you next week our
girls two non-binary folks to everybody
all inclusive bye
[Music]